Erstens muss ja Huckel noch erzählen, was er von der WWDC hält.
Interessiert mich jetzt nicht mehr.
Und zweitens kannst du ja mal das Thema ein bisschen einleiten, indem wir den Aspekt, den wir letztes Mal noch nicht so richtig gut kriegen.
Ja, ich hab mich letztes Mal so ein bisschen um Swift gedrückt.
Ich glaube insgesamt jetzt eine relativ kurze Analyse von uns.
Es gibt irgendwie so grob 100 Swift Evolution Proposals für Swift 3.
Das ist schön. Das ist wunderschön.
Na, zwei Dutzend fehlen noch irgendwie.
Ich glaube, das spielt nicht die entscheidende Rolle jetzt. Da wird wieder darüber diskutiert, sondern es geht darum, dass eben auch eine gewisse...
Also sie haben sich auch überlegt, was sind die Alternativen zu dem Proposal und warum wollen sie es jetzt genau so haben und warum nicht so?
Ich glaube, da kann man auch geteilter Meinung sein. Das ist auch das Recht von jedem, eine andere Meinung zu haben. Für solche Dinge bin ich auch offen. Keine Frage.
Sie hat noch nicht die Infrastruktur. Ich hab auf dem ersten SMSC von Vodafone gespielt und wenn man mehr als 30 Messages pro Sekunde gesehen hat, ist er tot umgefallen.
Genau, wir hatten ja damals dieses E-Gate bei E+, und da ging einfach 8.000 SMS am Tag drüber.
Am Tag?
Das musst du aber nochmal erklären, was das war.
Das war sozusagen eine, also wir haben halt damals gedacht, SMS hin und her, Textnachrichten hin und her schicken, mobil, eine große Revolution. Das war damals Mitte der 90er, war das halt wirklich revolutionär. Und dann haben wir gedacht, das muss doch irgendwie mit dem Computer zu verbinden sein und haben dann Telefone Nokia 2110s genommen, bzw. 2140s genommen, die wir an Computer gehängt haben und mit einer entsprechenden PCI-Karte dazwischen dann tatsächlich die als Modem verwenden konnten, um halt SMS zu versenden und zu empfangen. Und ja, und da haben wir dann mit vier Telefonen, glaube ich, das wurde dann halt von ganz vielen Leuten relativ schnell benutzt, weil wir dann da so Chatlisten, Chatrooms eingerichtet haben. Ja, da gab es dann so verschiedene Topics, unter anderem, was weiß ich, wo sind in der U-Bahn gerade die Kontrollettis und die gleichen Themen wie heute. Die Killer-Apps sozusagen. Zu allen möglichen Themen gab es dann plötzlich Chatlisten, wo sich halt immer mehr Leute darauf subscribt haben. Und es gab halt Mail zu SMS und SMS zu Mail Gateway und sogar zu Fax. Also SMS zu Fax und sowas.
Die gibt es zumindest immer noch, die funktioniert immer noch im Telekom-Netz.
Und dann waren das einfach sowas mit vier Telefonen, 8000 SMS am Tag. Und wir haben dann schon, E plus hatte damals zwei SMSCs, nämlich eins für die normalen SMS und eins für die Anrufbeantworter-SMS. Weil offensichtlich ein SMSC nicht genug Kapazität dafür hatte.
Die Voicebox schickte ja auch eine Nachricht.
Genau. Dann haben wir schon gemerkt, dass das Anrufbeantworter-SMSC weniger in Benutzung war. Dann haben wir also das genommen, weil das konnte man halt auch benutzen.
Würde man einfach einstellen und das wurde natürlich nicht überprüft.
Aber das ist auch, alle zwei, drei Tage ist das einfach stehen geblieben, aufgrund dieser wahnsinnigen Anzahl von 8000 SMS am Tag, die wir da drüber gejagt haben.
Man muss allerdings auch sagen, der ganze Grund dahinter, war, dass E plus die Dinge umsonst rausgetan hat damals.
Hast du eine Bestätigung bekommen dafür, dass das IG dafür verantwortlich war? Oder ist das nur eine Vermutung gewesen?
Nee, also wir waren da über eine Ecke mit Leuten bei E plus in Kontakt und die haben uns gehasst. Was allerdings das offizielle E plus Kundenmagazin nicht davon abgehalten hat, einfach so irgendwann als tollen Tipp zu veröffentlichen, wenn ihr eine E-Mail als SMS oder SMS als E-Mail verschicken wollt, dann macht das einfach über diese Mail-Adresse oder über diese Telefonnummer und die Telefonnummer vom E-Gate da veröffentlicht. Obwohl es da keinerlei offizielle...
Marketing. Ja, aber wie gesagt, als Hintergrund, die anderen haben ja das langsam eingefüllt und gechargt und hinterher und E plus ist ja später gekommen. Der ist ja drei, vier Jahre nach dem nach D1 und D2 gekommen. Und deswegen brauchten sie so ein paar Features, da sie ja auch initial nicht so diesen geilen Netzabdeckungen hatten, dass sie sagten, ja hier bei uns sind aber jetzt SMS kostenlos oder sowas.
Genau, SMS hat ja sowieso kaum jemand benutzt. Deshalb war es irgendwie billig und man konnte halt sagen, irgendwie so...
Macht mal.
Hatten die anderen eigentlich, die hatten doch am Anfang auch gar kein SMS?
D1, D2 oder was?
Telefone hatten oft nicht die Möglichkeit, SMS zu verschicken. Die hatten nur die ersten Telefone, konnten SMS nur empfangen.
Verschicken kam erst so ab dieser 21-10-Generation. Und dann hatte, wie gesagt, Vodafone hatte eins, da habe ich mitgespielt. 1993, 1994 stand in Düsseldorf da so ein Kästchen, so ein 19 Zoll Rack. Da war ja erst das SMSC drin. Und mit dem durfte ich dann mal spielen, auch direkt, also jetzt ohne Telefon, sondern damals noch per X25, per Datix P oder per lokalem X25, konnte man sich mit dem Ding connecten. Dann konnte man da per X25 mit dem UCP-Protokoll Messages reinschicken, die er dann brav ins Netz rausgeknallt hat. Und wenn du mehr als 30 davon geschickt hast pro Sekunde, dann machte das Ding mal kurz einen Carboid und brauchte so 5 Minuten zum Booten.
Falls du dich erinnerst, wir haben sogar eine Querverbindung eingerichtet, damit du auch Nachrichten nach E-Plus schicken konntest und wir Nachrichten nach Vodafone.
Das ging nämlich damals noch nicht, über das SS7. Weil die Kooperation bei den Netzbetreibern verboten.
Genau, deshalb ist ja eine Firma namens Dr. Materna so groß geworden. Weil die sich irgendwie hingestellt haben und dann den Traffic ausgetauscht haben zwischen den Netzbetreibern.
Dr. Materna hat sozusagen ein Pseudo- oder Software, so etwas ähnlich betrieben wie ein SMSC, aber das mit allen vier Netzen verbunden. Und darüber haben sie die Nachrichten ausgetauscht und da haben die sich auch dumm und dusselig daran verdient an dem Zeugs. Und irgendwann haben die Netzbetreiber dann doch mal jemand bei der Regierungsbehörde überzeugt, haben gesagt, hallo, ja, wir dürfen nicht miteinander kooperieren, aber Leute aus unseren Netzen dürfen sich auch gegenseitig anrufen. Also warum sollen die sich denn nicht auch gegenseitig Messages schicken können? Weil vorher war SMS so als netzinterner Dienst gesehen worden. Und dann hat man gesagt, nee, das ist aber was Globales und wir wollen vielleicht auch ins Ausland senden und das ist nicht alles. Und dann haben sie angefangen innerhalb Deutschlands Messages auch zuzulassen. Weil Ausland ging schon lange. Du konntest von Anfang an, an ausländische Teilnehmer Messages schicken, nur nicht von D1 nach D2 oder so. Das war so ein bisschen albern.
Wir wollen nochmal auf diesen Punkt zurückkommen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube, ich hatte vorhin irgendwie damit angefangen, aber nicht zu Ende gemacht. Zurück zu dem Cash-Chaos. Also SMS und Telefon, das war sozusagen das, womit diese Netzbetreiber eigentlich ihr Geld verdient haben. Ich glaube, SMS war lange, lange Zeit gut. Irgendwann kam Roaming sozusagen noch mit dazu oder ist wahrscheinlich auch immer noch so. Ich kenne jetzt die Zahlen nicht, was jetzt Ihnen wirklich Kohle bringt, aber im Vergleich zu den Investitionen, die Sie darin reinstecken müssen, auch bei SMS, also klar, da mussten Sie irgendwie so ein bisschen nachrüsten, aber das waren ja die teuersten Bits, die man überhaupt, glaube ich, kaufen konnte auf diesem Planeten.
Teurer als zur ISS.
Teurer als zur ISS was funken.
Ist, glaube ich, immer noch so.
Ja gut, mittlerweile sind dort die Preise wie auch im Keller, bzw. darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus. Wir befinden uns jetzt in diesem App-Wandel. Auf einmal spielen die eigentlichen Netzwerklayer nicht mehr so die Rolle, und auch dieser Wunsch der Betreiber dieser Netzwerklayer, nämlich auch diese Layer darüber zu beherrschen, also Payment zu beherrschen, Zugänge zu beherrschen, mit mangelnder Netzneutralität, Unterscheidungen zu machen. Wollen tun die das immer noch, aber ich denke, der Zug ist jetzt nicht nur abgefahren, sondern der ist irgendwie in höchster Geschwindigkeit in eine Richtung unterwegs, wo die jetzt auch überhaupt keine Chance mehr haben, bis zu so einem Punkt, wo ich jetzt auch glaube, dass sie langsam einsehen müssen, das sie das auch nicht mal einholen. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt hier, keine Ahnung hier, guckst du dir eine Bundesliga-Übertragung an, da wirbt doch tatsächlich die Post immer noch für ihren komischen, wie heißt das Ding?
Ebrie?
Simms?
Simse?
Also die deutsche Post hat so einen Messenger rausgebracht, den sie da ernsthaft irgendwie Simms genannt haben. Simsen.
Erinnert mich dunkel.
Dieses Wort kommt von dem immer gemeint, in der Zeitung immer stand, dass das angeblich Leute dazu sagen, was ich irgendwie nie nachvollziehen konnte. Es gibt sicherlich ein paar Leute, die das machen. Sie versuchen alles Mögliche, ihre alten Cashcars zu retten oder zumindest damit reinzugehen. Aber es geht jetzt ganz klar in die Messenger. Ich muss auch sagen, das ist von vielen unterschätzt worden. In gewisser Hinsicht auch von den Hackern und den ganzen Besserwissern im technischen Bereich, als ICQ und später dann AEM aufkamen. Also die allerersten Messenger, die im Prinzip auf der Funktionsbasis funktioniert haben, wie auch heute noch alle funktionieren. Du hast da irgendwie deinen Screenname und der ist irgendwie entscheidend. Dann bist du irgendwie online oder nicht und kannst halt irgendwie Nachrichten schicken. Die haben das ja im Prinzip popularisiert. ICQ war eigentlich der erste wirklich nennenswerte erfolgreiche Chat. Und später dann halt AEM. Und dann passiert dann wieder eine ganze Weile lang nichts. Sodass man auch schon wieder so ein bisschen in Vergessenheit geriet. Dann gab es diese kurze Phase mit, naja, man könnte ja mal ein Standard etablieren. So mit Java, wo dann Google mit angefangen hat, Facebook auch so ein bisschen. Da hat man ein bisschen mitgespielt. Was sie dann aber alles wieder haben, fallen lassen wie eine heiße Kartoffel, weil sie gesehen haben, dass eigentlich der Messenger die geilste Log-In-Methode, also mit CK-Methode der Neuzeit ist. Und dann fing es ja irgendwie an, nochmal mega diskruptiv zu werden, indem halt komplett neue Player auf den Tisch kamen, nämlich vor allem WhatsApp und dann später halt Line. Und wie heißt denn das Ding, was in Line ist, glaube ich, der in Japan so populär ist und der in China ist... Kriegst du jetzt gerade nicht hin. Aber wir haben im Prinzip so eine Landschaft von...
Weihweih oder irgendwie sowas?
Ja, es gibt so fünf oder sechs wirklich populäre Systeme. Facebook, WhatsApp ist ja im Prinzip dasselbe, auch wenn es irgendwie nochmal getrennt ist, aber es liegt ja sozusagen in der gleichen Company. Und dann fingen halt alle mehr oder weniger auch zeitgleich an, jetzt mit Telefonie anzufangen. Und das macht mich wahnsinnig, wenn ihr versucht, hier während der Sendung irgendwie fliegen zu fangen.
Alter, dann musst du deine Bude mal putzen.
Ich hab ja keine faulen Äpfel in der Ecke liegen, dass sie jetzt kommen. Die kommen alle nur wegen dir.
Deinetwegen, wenn schon.
Hau! Hau doch auf deine Tastatur. Wie viele Laptops schon dadurch zerstört worden sind. Ich film das, und dann geht das ab auf...
Aber den nervt die Fliege.
Fliegengate.
Mir ist das egal. Sollte die keiner ruhig irgendwie einen Pixel bilden, da oben auf dem Beamer, ist kein Problem. Sieht auch sehr schön aus.
Also so grob pixelig ist der Beamer nun auch nicht.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich versuchte eine technisch-philosophische Diskussion zu starten. Ich habe ja meinen Kernpunkt im Prinzip schon rübergebracht, damit hat Tobias ja angefangen, dass wir im Prinzip jetzt so einen Machtwechsel haben, der sich jetzt abzeichnet. Und ich frage mich halt, wie geht der aus?
Also was passiert jetzt?
Was übernimmt sozusagen die Kommunikation?
Die Macht wird sich konzentrieren, bis wieder irgendwelche Leute hinkommen und sagen, die gehen dir zu sehr auf den Sack und dann wird es radikal wieder abgeschaltet. Durch irgendjemanden. Durch staatliche Zensur oder keine Ahnung. Die Dinger fahren ja alle hoch und dann kommt irgendeiner, der für einen terroristischen Anschlag benutzt und dann wird das komplett gesperrt oder nicht. Also es ist halt sehr fragil. Es ändert sich sehr schnell.
Naja, oder? Oder es ist halt wie in China, dass es halt mit Unterstützung des Staates passiert und der totalen Kontrolle des Staates, sodass der Staat halt kein Interesse daran hat, das irgendwie abzuschalten, sondern das womöglich noch fördert.
Aber dafür schalten sie alles andere ab, um nicht eben zu konzentrieren.
Und damit ist es halt natürlich noch viel mehr konzentriert.
Viel einfacher überwachbarer als so ein komplett standardsbasierendes System, wo jeder irgendwie noch mal mit einer eigenen...
Oder Jabber. Das Schlimmste ist ja der Grund, warum die anderen Jabber, warum Google und Facebook-Jabber wieder abgeschaltet haben. Weil das ist ja federated. Da gibt es ja nicht einen zentralen Server, der ihnen gehört. Sondern da kann ja jeder seinen eigenen Server betreiben. Wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Na eben, kein Login halt. Login ist halt schon das Gebot der Stunde. Und das haben wir halt bei sozialen Netzwerken gesehen. Und Messenger sind ja im Prinzip das soziale Netzwerk 2.0. Also das ist sozusagen so Facebook ist. Wird es immer geben, also in verschiedenen Abstufen von immer. Aber das hat, sagen wir mal, das... Ich weiß nicht, bin mir nicht so sicher, ob ich das Ende von Facebook noch miterleben werde.
Hättest du von bei uns im ITF noch miterleben können.
Das Ende von Facebook? Ach, das hat schon stark gefunden?
Bei uns ja. Wir haben ja so ein Dauerding, was überwacht, ob wir aus dem ITF-Netz überall hinkommen. Und das schlug den an und sagte, Facebook ist von der IPv6-Welt verschwunden. Und da, für die andere gibt es für mich nicht mehr. Und deswegen war Facebook für mich einfach dann weg. Hat ein bisschen Panik ausgelöst, aber...
Es hat ja noch ein paar Instanzen, die irgendwo laufen.
Ja, sie haben es dann auch wieder repariert.
Es gibt auch ein paar Leute, die das benutzen. Nur die Bedeutung von dieser Art Plattform wandelt sich. Also Facebook war irgendwann mal das Neue. Und darüber wurden dann Posts geschert und so weiter. Also es hat auch teilweise diese Funktionalität des Neuigkeitenverbreitens gehabt. Aber was halt noch stärker als Neuigkeit verbreitet ist, ist halt miteinander unmittelbare soziale Kommunikation machen. Und das hat sie quasi in ihrem Chat-Element, was sie ja dann auch ausgegliedert haben, nachvollziehbar aus denselben Gründen, nämlich dass sie da schnell eine Innovation machen kann und eine App rausbringen kann, die eben jetzt nicht nur den ganzen Ballast des gesamten Facebooks noch mit dran hat. Wo sie dann eben Telefon... Ich weiß nicht, hat der Facebook-Messenger jetzt auch schon Telefonie mit drin? Hat er, ne?
Ich glaube, ich hab sowas gelesen.
Ich glaub's auch, aber manchmal kommt man ein bisschen durch an alle. Also im Prinzip alle haben das irgendwie, außer das Rima. Aber das Rima ist auch eh hinterher wie nichts.
Ja, ist doch gut so. Sie inventen aber langsam. Ja, sehr langsam.
Die könnten mal inventen, dass sie mir mal anzeigen, wenn ich eine Nachricht empfangen habe. Penner.
Kannste doch, glaube ich. Musst du drücken und halten oder irgendwie so was?
Ich habe da schon so viel gedrückt und gehalten, da kommt nichts. Wenn du morgens aufwachst und du siehst irgendwie Nachricht, dann weißt du nicht, wann die dir geschickt wurde, ob die vor fünf Sekunden oder vor fünf Stunden ankam.
Genau.
Wo denn?
In die Details.
Musst drücken und halten.
Dann kommt Details löschen, kopieren Details, dann kriegst du auf Details und dann kommt da Empfang bestätigt gesehen. Da kommen vier Uhrzeiten sogar. Na, geh mal auf eine Nachricht. Jetzt bringen wir Timmy mal ein bisschen Internet bei hier.
Ich kann auch nur Daumen hoch, Daumen runter, kopieren, teilen, löschen.
Kopieren, teilen, löschen.
Ja, aber das geht irgendwo.
Ich hatte das auch schon mal gesehen.
Da steht das Datum, da steht die Uhrzeit.
Da steht ein Datum, wenn ein Tagwechsel ist.
Ja, und da drunter steht die Uhrzeit.
Das heißt, die Uhrzeit steht nur, wenn du... Was?
Da steht die Uhrzeit.
Wieso steht bei dir, wenn du das versendest?
Nee, das ist das, was da gekommen ist. Oder das ist das, was von drüben kam, da 1634.
Wieso stehen bei dir Zeiten und bei mir nicht?
Guck mal.
Weil ich netter bin.
Aber es stimmt schon, es betrifft deine eigene Nachricht, richtig? Wann die gelesen wurde.
Nee, ich sehe hier keine...
Nee, bei Tobias jetzt. Also für die Nachrichten, die ich versende, kann ich sehen, wann sie versendet und angekommen und wann sie gelesen wurde. Aber für die Nachrichten, die ich kriege, sehe ich immer nur dann, wann sie...
Nee, hier gucke, das ist für eine Nachricht, die ich gekriegt habe. Wann sie gesendet wurde und wann ich sie bekommen habe.
Er hat allerdings auch einen Druiden-Client, muss man sagen.
Ja, ich habe hier einen anderen Client.
Auf dem iOS-Client sehe ich eine andere.
Für meine Nachricht machen...
Unter iOS ist da nichts zu sehen.
Hier Details kann ich das machen. Aber für Nachrichten, die ich bekomme, da...
Da gibt es dieses Ding nicht. Vielleicht kann man das einstellen. Vielleicht kann man das einstellen.
Hier drauf hält noch die eigene Nachricht.
Ah, Zeit beim Fangen anzeigen. Okay, ich nehme alles zurück.
Was, wie, wo? Muss man das einstellen?
Es gibt ein Setting dafür.
Live in einer Freak Show gibt es nirgends woanders. Bei Notifications nehme ich an.
Oder wo? Settings, Chat-Anzeige.
Chat-Display. Received Message Time habe ich doch an. Ja, aber bei mir kommt trotzdem nichts.
Naja, sie könnten einfach mal die Nachricht auf der Scheiß-Uhr anzeigen. Das können sie auch nicht. Ist ja auch egal. Auf jeden Fall, Innovation findet in Messenger statt, wenn bei Streamer auch mal etwas später.
Wenn man sie dann findet.
Jetzt mit Stickern. Der neue heiße Scheiß-Stick.
Ja, genau, das Streamer hat keine Sticker.
Aber WhatsApp, die anderen nasen alle.
Ja, da ist ja auch wirklich noch eine ganze Menge zu holen in diesem Bereich. Deswegen glaube ich halt, dass auch die Messenger so ein bisschen jetzt auch so die neuen Motoren sein werden für oder längst sind. Für wie private und so teilprivate, also so gruppenbasierte Kommunikation so läuft. Weil E-Mail ist halt irgendwie so scheiße geblieben.
Das ist der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner.
Das ist halt wieder das Faxgerät des Internets.
Kein Login.
Ja, kein Login, genau.
Was halt dann auch heißt, wenn du was ändern willst, musst du halt warten, bis alle anderen das auch geändert haben.
Ja, aber es ist natürlich absurd, dass Mail nicht besser wird, aber trotzdem auch das Sicherheits-Backend ist für alle anderen Dienste.
Ja, das ist geil.
Das kleinste gemeinsame Nenner.
Das ist einfach geil.
Deswegen wird übrigens auch die SMS nicht sterben. Oder der SMS heißt es ja.
Also ich habe kein Problem mit einem kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner, wenn der nicht so klein ist.
Ist halt Installed Base. Und ist eben nicht von einem Konzern kontrolliert. Installed Base bei WhatsApp ist auch groß, aber sämtliche Apps kommen ausschließlich von ihnen. Stell dir mal vor, WhatsApp würde jetzt auf die Idee kommen, auf die dämliche Idee kommen, sei es auch nur eine Plug-In-Schnittstelle oder irgendetwas Ähnliches für ihr Ding anzubieten. Dann gäbe es plötzlich 30 Millionen Anbieter, die da ihr Plug-Ins für bauen würden. Und dann hast du das übliche Problem, dass du nicht schnell genug weitergehen kannst, weil sonst die ganzen Plug-Ins nicht mehr funktionieren, blablabla, dann kommt dieses System zum Halten mit der Innovation. Solange du das proprietär im Haus hast, kannst du das so schnell entwickeln, wie du willst. Genauso wie der Apple, mit seinem FaceTime oder iMessage da. Das ist allein ihr Ökosystem mit ihrem Zeug, das heißt, da können sie jetzt in iMessage Sticker einbauen, ohne dass irgendeiner kräht. Wer soll da auch krähen? Das ist ja nur ihre eigene Applikation.
Ich habe mitbekommen, dass sie genau das jetzt getan haben, Plugins.
Deswegen sage ich es ja. Ich wundere mich jetzt zum Beispiel gerade, weil die Frage ist, Apple ist halt auch ein bisschen frech. Ich glaube nicht, dass da irgendeins dieser Plugins, die es da geben könnte oder diese Schnittstellen, dass irgendeine so groß wird, dass sie die Marktmacht von Apple an dem eigentlichen Urprodukt sozusagen überschreiten. Das heißt, Apple wird dann halt eben einfach weitergehen sagen, wir machen jetzt die Innovation und ihr habt bis dahin dann Zeit, eure Plugins zu updaten, sonst fliegt der raus.
Die Sticker selber sind ja noch nicht mal Code, der läuft. Das ist ja nur ein Bundle, wo Bilder drin sind, die in einem bestimmten Format vorliegen.
Aber es kann ja nicht ewig so weitergehen.
Du kannst aber jetzt auch andere Apps da einhängen, sodass du so Payment implementieren kannst oder irgendwelche anderen Mechanismen.
Ja, du hast diese komischen, wie nennen die sich? iMessage-Apps, was so eine Art App, die im Messenger, also eine App, die im Messenger läuft und irgendwie einen Shared-State hat über die Teilnehmer der Message, diese Chat-Message-Verbindung.
Damit man halt eben so sein eigenes Bild implementieren kann. Ich hab mir das so genau noch nicht angeschaut.
Gibt's aber nur für iOS, ne? Gibt's nicht für MacOS.
Ach, gibt's nicht für MacOS? Nein. Wahrscheinlich, weil der Rechner, der MacOS, ist immer noch nicht kontrolliert genug für Apple. Da gibt's immer noch Leute, die dann so ein Terminal aufrufen und da eigene Programme drauf laufen lassen, die dann Apple nicht zertifiziert hat. Und dann haben sie Angst, dass ihnen jemand einen Spammer baut.
Nee, das glaub ich, daran liegt's, glaub ich, nicht. Sondern das ist einfach nicht mehr der Markt für die. Das ist wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich sehen sie es halt auch sehr als Consumer-Feature. Und das brauchen sie dann auf dem Desktop nicht.
Und Tobias, du bist ja hier eigentlich auch, warst du, ich glaub, auch ein Linux-Hacker früher, ne? Mit so T60 oder so, ich glaub, du warst ja auch der, hast du mal erzählt. Du hattest ein IBM, also damals noch IBM, Syncpad. Du wolltest irgendwie das fette Display haben, gab's aber nicht. Und das dann, dein 4 zu 3 Display oder sowas hast du ausgebaut. Und nee, das war die Auflösung, nicht das Aspektratio, ne?
Genau.
Das hast du von einem anderen Laptop irgendwie das 1920 x 1200 Display ausgebaut und in deinem wieder eingebaut und das hat funktioniert.
Ja, es war 1600 x irgendwas, weil es danach nur noch eine geringere Auflösung gab. Beziehungsweise genau, der A30P hatte eine höhere Auflösung als der T60P. Genau, ich sauge mir das so lange her.
Naja, das ist der Fallen Ovo und so, aber ich kann mich nicht erinnern, du warst also auch da schwer am Basteln irgendwie.
Seit wann hast du den Max?
Seit 2013 oder so?
Also noch nicht so lange.
Und, wie ist's?
Na, man gewöhnt sich dran.
Das ist wie bei Martin, man gewöhnt sich dran. Das schmeckt nicht, aber man gewöhnt sich dran.
Ja, aber ich meine, warum?
Weil ich mal wollte, dass irgendwie so Suspend und WLAN funktionieren.
So klappt man auch, weil sein Computer, der funktioniert.
Ich wollte einfach, ich hatte irgendwie 18 Jahre, war ich sozusagen im Linux auf dem Desktop, Underground.
Minority.
Aber das soll doch jetzt kommen, habe ich gehört.
Das ist ja auch alles total schön und gut und ich habe das ja auch gerne gemacht, aber irgendwie hat sich dann irgendwann doch so ein bisschen wiederholt. Und ich hatte dann irgendwie, war mir dann irgendwann die Lust drauf vergangen, da weiter an den immer selben Stellen zu basteln. Ja genau, und da ich, ich war da ja nie so, ich bin da eigentlich recht pragmatisch. Linux hatte ich halt, weil das hat gut funktioniert für mich und dann hat es halt irgendwann nicht mehr so gut funktioniert für mich und dann wollte ich halt was anderes haben, aber vor Windows hatte ich zu große Angst, weil das dann ja doch irgendwie ganz anders ist. Und, ähm, also nachdem ich dann irgendwann mein MacBook hatte und eine Freundin da irgendwie draufguckte und auf meinen Desktop sah, meinte sie irgendwie, sie sieht ja genauso aus wie bei deinem Linux Laptop, weil ich einfach genau dieselben Terminals in genau der gleichen Anordnung wie vorher da irgendwie wieder hatte.
Du hast jetzt deinen Deckel zuklappen konntest und es ist auch wieder aufgewacht danach und das WLAN ging auch immer idea maske.
Was da alles irgendwie für Stranger-Probleme waren irgendwie immer, ich meine, das hat ja im Prinzip funktioniert, ja, aber dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, hatte ich da irgendwie so ein Bug. Suspend hat, bei jedem 16. Aufwachen ist die Kiste stehen geblieben und äh... Und dann gab's immer irgendwie, gab's halt immer Arti-Grafikkarten-Treiber-Updates und dann funktionierte halt das wieder nicht. Dann ging jenes nicht, aber du brauchst jetzt den Treiber, weil du sonst das Update nicht mehr installieren konntest und so. Ich meine, klar ist ja auch viel schwieriger. Ich meine, bei Apple, da ist halt wieder, das ist nur wieder bei dem Login, da kommt das alles aus einer Hand. Und natürlich haben sie es dann auch in der Hand, das irgendwie alles passend zu machen. Und ich muss halt sagen, dafür haben sie das, also ich hatte, hab mir dieses MacBook Pro Retina gekauft, als das neu rauskam. Und das hat wirklich lange gedauert, bis sie da so, also die gröbsten Fehler so rauskamen.
Ja, aber Edimit, da kann ich mich aber auch erinnern, du hast doch gleich so einen Hack benutzt, weil du eben nicht die doppelte Auflösung, aber die Pixel waren also ein Punkt, war vier Pixel groß, sondern du hast das, du wolltest ja natürlich die native Bildschirmauflösung haben und hast das schon wieder rumgehackt, also...
Naja, das kann man doch einstellen. Nee, du kannst es nicht so einstellen, dass tatsächlich die volle Auflösung ausgenutzt wird, der skaliert das halt immer so ein bisschen.
Du kannst es nicht unretina benutzen.
Und dann habe ich das mal ein paar Tage lang tatsächlich so benutzt, in der vollen Auflösung, aber dann war irgendwann der Fettfilm von meiner Nasenspitze auf dem Display, war dann doch irgendwie etwas lästig und deshalb habe ich das dann wieder sein gelassen.
Was ist deine maximale Anzahl von Terminals, die du so drauf hast? Wenn, dann, in so...
Na ja, also, ich weiß nicht, das sind halt...
Ja, du benutzt Screens, ok.
Ich habe schon seit 25 Jahren einen neuen Mal neuen Layout an Screens, an virtuellen Desktops. Das benutze ich auch weiterhin.
Und wie sind so deine sonstigen Erfahrungen mit dem Plattformwechsel? Also 2013, das heißt, sein erstes OS war was? 10...
8? 10.8, genau.
Der gute Schneeleopard.
Genau, und...
Schneeleopard war 10.6.
Nee, Mountain Lion war 10.6.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das nächste OS heißt.
10.7 war Lion, 10.8 war Mountain Lion, 10.9 war, wie hieß es noch gleich?
Yosemite, Maverick? Ne, was mit Mavericks?
Genau, Mavericks.
10.8 war Maverick. Ne, 10.9 war Maverick, 10.10 war Yosemite. Ich weiß jedenfalls, wie das nächste heißt. Und zwar Sierra Leone.
Okay, aber jetzt nochmal deine... Das würde mich jetzt wirklich mal interessieren. Also sozusagen so viel andere OS-Prägung und jetzt kommt es auf den Neck, dann schaut man doch anders drauf, als wenn man das irgendwie schon 20 Jahre vor der Nase hat.
Darauf hast du die Jahrzehnte gewartet, mich das fragen zu können.
Deswegen habe ich das ja gerade aufgemacht, das Thema. Außer mich das ja mal interessant bei anderen zu wissen.
Würde mich wirklich interessieren, also the good, the bad, the ugly.
Ähm, Suspend und WLAN funktionieren.
Okay, das hatten wir schon. Das war das Gute.
Gab es noch was Gutes? Also was mich total nervt, ist, dass es halt irgendwie keine funktionierende Paketverwaltung gibt. So, wenn du da diese PKGs hast...
Du kaufst vielleicht dein Zeug im Mac App Store. Hallo?
Homebrew? Also Homebrew ist für dich nichts oder was?
Nee, aber du hörst doch ganz oft, dass du halt irgendwie dir so PKGs runterlädst und installieren musst. Ja, aber ich krieg halt irgendwie, ich muss aus beruflichen Gründen irgendwie so Microsoft-Produkte benutzen. Die kommen als PKG und die gibt's nicht in Homebrew.
Ja, aber was machst du da unter Linux mit denen?
Microsoft? Natürlich.
Aber was machst du unter Linux mit den Paketen?
Na, da kann ich sie installieren und wieder deinstallieren.
Unter Linux, Microsoft-Pakete?
Nee, Microsoft-Pakete da natürlich nicht, es sei dann, ich hab sie in...
Ich verstehe jetzt auch nicht, wovon du redest. Also, was ist unter Linux dann besser, wenn es da auch nicht ging?
Nimm irgendwas anderes, was halt nicht in Homebrew verfügbar ist, was es halt nur zum Runterladen von dem Anbieter als fertiges PKG gibt.
Ja, ok, dann sagen wir mal so, unter Linux war das Paketsystem, da gab es mehr Pakete.
Ja, es gibt nur ein Paketsystem, und auf Mac gibt es halt die Installer, also PKG.
Genau, ich meine, mich nervt einfach, dass es dafür keine... dass man die halt nicht vernünftig wieder aninstallieren kann.
Ja, aber das eigentlich kann man aninstallieren, und zwar wählt man die App aus und löscht die.
Ja, das ist aber nicht so.
Ja, weil die meisten Apps das nicht ordentlich machen.
Genau, aber das kannst du ja nur so machen bei Sachen, die du halt als Application in den Applications-Folder gezogen hast. Aber diese PKG-Installer, da geht das halt nicht.
Doch, es gibt so ein Produkt.
Du hast ja auch noch diese ganzen Launch-Agents, die dann irgendwie installiert werden in Slash-Library und hast nicht gesehen, nur noch eine Kernel-Exzension, die dazugehört usw. Und das Ganze kannst du halt nach wie vor nur machen, wenn der Hersteller, der dir den Installer liefert, mit diesem Installer auch noch einen Uninstaller liefert. Aber das OS selber ist nicht in der Lage, etwas, was mal installiert wurde, was ich auch wirklich absurd finde. Zumal ja das auch mitloggt und es gibt ja dann Resid-File.
Ja, das ging mal. Nein, der Installer selber konnte das mal, weil du hast ja in dem Installer selber einen BOM, Bill of Materials-File drin, was genau mitloggt, was wohin kopiert wird. Früher gab es für diesen Installer eben auch das Uninstall-Kommando, was dir nach dieser Liste von installierten Dingen alles wieder aus dem System entfernt hat. Aber das ist irgendwo 10.1, 10.2 verloren gegangen.
Ja, ich meine, dieses OS ist ja noch nicht mal in der Lage, einem auch überhaupt mal halbwegs konsistent anzuzeigen, was überhaupt installiert ist auf diesem Computer. Ich meine, das musste der ja immer noch alles selber zusammensuchen. Also das finde ich auch wirklich ein Drama. Okay, point taken.
Ja, ansonsten...
Was ist noch schlecht?
Ja, ich weiß halt weniger, was das so im Hintergrund tut. Dann lese ich jetzt halt, du musst dieses abstellen und jenes abstellen, sonst werden alle deine Suchanfragen da und dahin geschickt und bei Spotlight jenes Häkchen wegmachen und sowas halt. Ja, aber im Großen und Ganzen habe ich mich jetzt auch mit dem Betriebssystem... Ich bin ja halt User. So, und dafür funktioniert es halt ausreichend gut. Es funktioniert für meinen jetzigen Use-Case besser als vorher meinen Linux. Also ich muss mich einfach weniger darum kümmern.
Ja, aber das ist doch sicherlich auch so ein bisschen Gewöhnungssache. Also ich habe jetzt so einen Raspian mal auf dem Raspberry Pi installiert und dann ging die Uhr nicht richtig. Ja, und jetzt? Wie stellt man auf dem Ding die Uhr? War nicht rauszufinden. Also über die Oberfläche nicht. Da kann man diverse andere Sachen einstellen.
NTP Dateman.
Kannst du nicht anklicken mit der Maus?
Terminal heißt es da.
Und warum läuft das Ding nicht von alleine? Also ich meine, das Teil hat ja Netz. Es ist irgendwie so...
Ja, was wäre es denn ein NTP Server? Dass es Public NTP Server gibt, hat vielleicht noch nicht jeder herausgefunden oder so.
Also man kann die Zeitzone kann man über das Interface einstellen, aber nicht die Uhr. Also es ist total bekloppt. Dann geht die Uhr dann zwei Stunden mehr falsch, wenn du die richtige Zeitzone einstellst.
Aber ich habe mir schon vorgenommen, als nächstes, wenn ich dann irgendwann vielleicht in ein paar Jahren von OSX oder Mac OS genervt bin, dann muss halt auch nochmal Windows dran kommen.
Wenn es das da noch gibt.
Das habe ich übrigens auch versucht auf dem Pi zu installieren. Mit NOOBS. NOOBS ist ja so ein quasi Betriebssystem Installer. NOOBS.
So N-O-O-B-S.
Ja, genau.
Das ist ein Image für eine SD-Karte. Wird dir denn erlaubt, das eigentliche Ding zu installieren?
Dann fährst du das NOOBS hoch, gibst es dir im Netz, und dann zeigt er dir so sechs verschiedene Distributionen an, die er dir anbietet, zu installieren. Und da ist auch ein Windows 10 IoT, Internet of Things, dabei. Und dann musst du, dann dachte ich, ah, das klickst du jetzt an, das versuchst du mal. Dann tut er irgendwas, dann musst du irgendwelche komischen Bedingungen abhaken. Und dann musst du dir einen Account machen, bei Windows sonst wie. Oder Microsoft, oder weiß ich nicht, habe ich den Account gemacht. Dann sagt er noch, ja, man muss aber hier irgendwie Developer werden. Er setzt halt so ein Häkchen, sagt okay, und bestätigt noch die E-Mail, die natürlich irgendwo anders hingeht. Und das war's dann. Dann habe ich diesen Prozess drei, vier Mal gemacht und bin nicht weitergekommen. Keine Ahnung, wie immer das jetzt ist.
Vielleicht haben die dieses Windows für den Raspberry Pier mit dem Zweier Raspberry Pi rausgebracht, oder? Erst mit dem Dreier? Sicher? Weil den Dreier gibt es erst seit zwei, drei Monaten, oder?
Seit Anfang des Jahres. Stimmt, eigentlich müsste das auch für den Zweier schon.
Ja, weil da müsste auf dem Dreier eigentlich einigermaßen schon flutschen, oder?
Also diesen Nux, wer mal mit dem Pi rumbasteln will, das ist ganz schick.
Ja, ist halt so ein Grab-Back-Thing. Du bist ja erst mal rein und kannst dann sagen, ich hätte jetzt gerne das und das da noch, oder ein Raspian, oder ein Lalalala, oder ein... keine Ahnung, was die...
Weil das ist jetzt nur für einen Raspberry, das ist nicht für einen Mac.
Nein, das ist nur für einen Raspberry.
Ich hab dann auch versucht, mal ein Ubuntu drauf zu machen, aber dann musste er irgendwelche komischen gepatchten Dinger da installieren, die von sonst woher kommen, und dann bleiben die beim Booten hängen. Immer das erste Mal sagt er irgendwelche komischen, zyklischen Referenzen hat er jetzt gefunden, und er müsste jetzt nochmal booten. Das heißt, er bootet nur jedes zweite Mal so weit, dass du dich einlocken kannst. Und sonst ist es völlig, also irgendwie, da geht überhaupt nichts.
Wo wir gerade noch bei MechOS sind, gerade so, ich hab mir mal die MechOS Sierra Beta installiert.
Ja, hab ich auch gerade gemacht. Hat funktioniert. Ja, eben gerade gemacht.
Und, kriegste Software-Updates angeboten?
Ja, ist hängen geblieben dabei. Also er ist hier, hat, warte kurz, muss klicken. Der wollte hier iTunes 12.5 und Safari Technology Preview 8 runterladen. Hängt irgendwie in der Mitte davon.
In der Mitte, aber hier hängt er immer bei null Bytes.
Also er hat es anscheinend runtergeladen und beim Installing steht er da irgendwie. Aber zu Hause auf meinem Mac Pro habe ich das auch gemacht und da hat das funktioniert.
Das scheint mir auf jeden Fall noch sehr wackelig zu sein.
Ganz schön Beta, ne?
Ganz schön Beta, aber vor allem ist mir dann nach dem Installieren auch so klar geworden, so, das sind eigentlich gar keine Features dabei, die mich irgendwie interessieren.
Ja doch, ich wollte mal dieses, dass es die Oberfläche in Metal ist, das wollte ich mal fühlen, ob das irgendwie flutschiger ist, aber ich kann ja auch keinen Unterschied feststellen, das ist genauso flutschig wie immer.
Wie stellt man das ein?
Das ist immer so jetzt.
Die Oberfläche was?
Das ist in Metal, die Grui. Die erinnern nicht mehr mit OpenGL oder was auch immer, sondern jetzt mit Metal.
Metal ist sozusagen das neue 3D-API von OSX oder Mac OS.
Das ist vergleichbar mit Microsofts Direct 3D, heißt das bei denen, ne?
Direct 3D beziehungsweise, wie heißt es jetzt, der neue... Vulkan, genau. Also sozusagen, neue... OpenGL ist ja so uralt und die war ja damals quasi auf die alte Hardware angepasst und Metal und diese ganzen Nachfolgegenerationen sind jetzt quasi an die, wie das heute so ist, angepasst.
Mehr so low-level und schneller und so weiter.
Genau. Ja, also von daher, da kann man irgendwie gar nicht so viel drüber sagen, außer dass sie so grundsätzlich eigentlich eine relativ gute Stabilität mittlerweile hinbekommen. Also wenn sie jetzt irgendwie ankündigen, dass da eine Beta ist, dann ist das nicht mehr so ein Crashpot.
Das ist das, was sie früher rausgebracht hätten.
Wer nicht gar null erlebt hat. Nee, aber es stimmt schon, die Betas, also auch die iOS-Beta ist ziemlich solide.
Du hast doch noch noch irgendwas ausgegraben. Ich hätte mir das kurz notiert, als du es getwittert hast, Dennis.
Ja, ich bin mir aber auch schon gar nicht mehr so sicher. Also die Sache ist die, ich habe ja hier so ein Sennheiser Momentum 2. Weil, ein bisschen Werbung machen, ne? Bluetooth-Kopfhörer. Und es gibt bei Bluetooth halt diesen, weiß nicht wie die Standard da genau heißen, aber wenn du dann Audio darüber hören willst, dann nutzen sie den SBC-Codec. Und der ist halt so lala. Und der neuere Codec, den man benutzen kann, heißt APTX. Und Anfang des Jahres hier unter El Capitan hat mir jemand gesagt, hier, du kannst da im Bluetooth-Explorer oder so, da kann man das Gerät dazu zwingen, dass er immer diesen APTX nimmt. Das heißt, das El Capitan konnte APTX schon, hat es aber per default nicht gemacht, sondern hat diesen SBC-Codec benutzt. Na, so eine Art Audiokodec könnte man mal vereinfacht sagen.
Nicht so eine Art, es ist ein Audiokodec.
Ja, wenn man dir einen Doku liest, dann hört sich das immer alles sehr komisch an.
Na, es ist ein Audiokodec von Qualcomm. Also ich wundere mich so ein bisschen, dass wir noch in Zeiten leben, wo proprietäre Audiokodecs noch ein New Thing sind.
Na ja, wenn da steht, was developed in the 80s.
Das ist gerade das tolle Ding. Ist egal. Jedenfalls in El Capitan ist dafür Support schon drin, aber es wird per Default nicht benutzt. Und dann wird dieses SPC benutzt, was nicht ganz so toll ist. Und dann habe ich letztens meinen Mac Pro mit Serif versorgt, habe meine Kopfhörer da dran, dachte, guckst du einfach mal so rein, wie man halt immer so guckt. Und dann habe ich gesehen, dass es schon dieses aptX benutzt und habe das dann halt mal getweetet. Wie siehst du das denn? Das ist ganz einfach, wenn man diesen Kopfhörer mit seinem Rechner gepaart hat und dann auch Musik läuft, weil wenn nichts läuft, dann passiert halt nichts, aber man muss schon Musik oder irgendwie Audio anhaben, dann drückt man mit ALT oben im Menü auf das Bluetooth-Zeichen. Wenn man es denn da drin hat, wenn nicht, muss man es einschalten, dass das da oben kommt. Dann geht man zu seinem Kopfhörer und dann ist da so ein Eintrag, welcher Codec gerade benutzt wird. Bei mir ist ja natürlich jetzt nicht Rody, weil ich habe erstens den Kopfhörer nicht dabei, und zweitens läuft keine Musik. Und zweitens ist es basierend auf erstens schon eigentlich.
Das hängt so ein bisschen zusammen, meinst du?
Jedenfalls habe ich dann gesehen, dass mein El Capitan, mein Laptop hier, obwohl da nichts eingestellt ist, bin ich der Meinung, auch schon APTX benutzt. Das kann sein, dass die das grundsätzlich in den letzten Monaten einfach mal zum Default erklärt haben. Oder da ist irgendein anderes Voodoo dahinter, dass es vielleicht das iTunes-Managed, was man da hat oder so. Also irgendwas hat jetzt jedenfalls APTX aktiviert.
Hast du das mal gegen Bose Soundlink getestet?
Ja, komischerweise wird dort nicht mal irgendein Codec angezeigt. Was aber an einer anderen Sache liegen kann, und zwar gibt es ja noch eine weitere Methode, wie man Audio zu einem Bluetooth-Device kriegt. Und zwar, indem die das File halt direkt, das ist ja schon...
Mach mal was draus.
RAW ist ja auch schon ein Endcode, und dann schicken die das File hin, als AAC zum Beispiel, und dann nimmt das Device das selber auseinander. Und die Vermutung ist, dass das iPhone das auch so macht, weil viele Rätseln, ob das iPhone jetzt endlich mal diesen AptX kann. Aber da habe ich auch die Vermutung, weil irgendein Hersteller meinte, der ihr Kopfhörer macht mit den iPhones kein AptX, aber es wäre kein Problem, weil das iPhone würde ja AAC direkt schicken. Das kann man halt nicht checken irgendwie mit seinem Kopfhörer, weil da kein Lämpchen ist, was irgendwie angeht, oder anzeigt, wie das nun gerade gemacht wird. Aber das könnte so die Vermutung sein, weil das iPhone ja eh nur AAC abspielt und das Gerät, wenn das AAC halt kann, das dann direkt, also selber decodet, was auch Sinn machen würde, aber weiß ich halt nicht genau, kann ich nicht sagen. Das ist jedenfalls das, was ich da so gesehen habe mit diesem AptX.
Verstehe.
Und sonst habe ich ja auch noch nicht so richtig viel gesehen. Ich habe Siri zweimal probiert, dann habe ich es noch ein drittes Mal probiert, dann hat er mich nicht verstanden, dann habe ich es ausgestellt. Immerhin die ersten beiden Male. Ich dachte schon, ich...
Du hast es gleich beim dritten Mal aufgegeben.
Ich fasele mal da rein, so ohne Betonung, ohne alles, wie immer. Hat er tatsächlich erkannt, da war ich ein bisschen erstaunt. Das war früher nicht so. Das hat schon besser geworden. Aber beim dritten Mal hat es halt... Vor allem, ich wollte irgendwas nur wissen. Und der hat irgendwie verstanden, ich will jemanden anrufen. Und dann fängt er ja auch immer gleich an zu wählen. Die könnte ja noch so... Hab ich richtig verstanden, du willst jemanden anrufen. Das würde ich ja noch verstehen. Aber nein, er wählt ja auch immer gleich sofort los. Keine Ahnung, hab ich nicht gesehen. War ja mein Rechner... Naja, die sind ja gekoppelt irgendwie. Vielleicht konnte er auch nicht wählen. Aber da stand da, dass er wählen will. Dann kriegst du gleich schon wieder so einen Panikmodus, drückst auf alle Tasten, und du denkst, was Stopp bedeuten könnte. Und dann hab ich es auch schon gleich sofort wieder ausgemacht. Das geht gar nicht. Und sonst hab ich noch nicht allzu viel entdeckt, irgendwie muss ich sagen. Also ich hab jetzt mit, wie heißt es, APFS, hab ich noch nicht gespielt, kommt aber demnächst noch.
Also ich hab irgendwann mal so ein Disc-Image angelegt mit APFS.
Ja, aber du hast noch mit dem Developer-Ding getestet und nicht mit dem Beta, richtig? Mit dem Beta 1.
Mit dem Beta 1 hab ich's getestet, ja.
Du hast das vorher mit dem Developer-Preview gemacht.
Ja, mit Developer-Preview 1, das erste, was es gab. Und hab ein paar Dateien reingesetzt und hab mich gefreut, dass der Finder sehr schnell die Größen anzeigt und Womit kann man denn... und Duplicate irgendwie instantan ist und keine Dings verbraucht und dann war's das.
Womit kann man das denn anlegen?
Also, du kannst mit HD-IOTIL ein Disk Image erzeugen. Und dieses Disk Image kann ein APFS-Disk Image sein.
Und das ist der einzige Wege, wie es geht.
Ja, nicht übers Kuhi.
Haben sie absichtlich nicht gemacht.
Aber man kann auch auf einer externen Platte...
Das hab ich nicht ausprobiert, weil sie es auch in dem Talk auf der WWDC mit einem Disk Image gemacht haben. Und ich da jetzt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, irgendwie auch jetzt nicht...
Gib mir den USB-Stick und wir testen das.
Ich hab ja auch richtige Festplatten.
Ja, das muss man ja nicht, aber so einen 8 Zoll Monster geben. Eben, hast ja Sierra auch irgendwo, ja?
Ich hab jetzt hier Sierra drauf, einfach um meine Neugier ein bisschen zu befriedigen, aber es war halt nicht so richtig viel zu holen, von daher ist da irgendwie auch nicht so richtig viel.
Nee, es ist halt gar nicht so viel geändert, oder?
Auch dieses APFS ist halt irgendwie so... Ja, da hat man jetzt ein Disk-Image, das sieht nicht anders aus und verhält sich auch nicht viel anders als ein anderes Disk-Image, weißt du so?
Na gut, so lange jetzt keine Snapshots, die gibt's ja noch nicht, ne?
Nee, die sind glaube ich noch nicht...
Ich weiß halt nicht, wie der Stand da in dem User-Beta ist.
Das weiß ich auch nicht, also ich hab's dann auch nicht nochmal probiert, weil so dieses, ich installiere halt auf eine externe Festplatte, eine Beta-Version von einem Betriebssystem, das machst du dann, dann lässt du das eine halbe Stunde laufen, klickst drin rum und irgendwann denkst du dir so, okay, jetzt ist aber dann doch ein bisschen einsam hier und bootest wieder zurück, wo was los ist.
Tobias, auf deinem Laptop, welche Generationen, was hast du für Schnittstellen?
Kein Internet.
Also du hast USB 3, ne? Welche Benutzung? Gibt es auch welche Schnittstellen, die du nicht benutzt?
Äh, lass mich gucken.
SD-Karte.
Die Kopfhörerbuchse benutze ich nicht.
Die wird eh bald abgeschafft.
Alle anderen benutze ich.
Du hörst nie Musik mit deinem Laptop? Und wenn dann über...
Wir hatten ja hier eine sehr mehrere Diskussionen über das Sterben von Ports und dem Ausblick, dass künftig alles nur noch USB-C ist am Laptop und alles nur noch Lightning auf dem Telefon. Und dann gab es da viel Diskussionen. Und dann hat mal jemand sich die Mühe gemacht. Das ging hier vor ein paar Wochen rum. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gesehen habt.
Das ist der Ultimate Apple IO.
Death Chart. Wo alle I.O.-Devices in der Zeit markiert wurden, wie lange die tatsächlich existiert. Und dann halt auf dem iPhone 30-Pin-Interface Lightning.
Thunderbolt und Lightning.
Und ganz unten der Headphone Jack über die gesamte Breite.
Genau, und der Headphone Jack ist auch tatsächlich die einzige Schnittstelle, die wirklich an jedem Mac ever immer dabei war. Du weißt, ohne Mikrofon keine Teilnahme am Gespräch.
Er hat sich gewandelt. Er hat ja auch mal eine Zeit lang rot geleuchtet, weil er noch ein Toslink drin hatte.
Und der hat sich auch gewandelt, weil die Headphones vom iPhone ja unterstützt haben, also dass man auch dieses Remote-Zeugs benutzen kann. Vielleicht hat sich der auch so lange gehalten, weil er einfach schon perfekt ist. Er ist halt relativ klein, tut, was er soll. Und ja, muss gar nicht so viel besser werden an sich jetzt erstmal.
Genau, aber unabhängig von dem Headphone-Jack, es gab fast, also leider ist das jetzt hier, dieser Grafik nur sehr schlecht zu entnehmen, aber ich glaube, im Mittel haben die Schnittstellen maximal 15 Jahre überdauert, wenn ich das hier so richtig sehe.
Er schrieb sowas im Text, ungefähr 15 Jahre.
Genau, ungefähr 15 Jahre, also das gilt sowohl für ADB, SCSI, auch die Floppy Drive war nur geringfügig länger da, die CD war auch nicht länger da, DVD auch nicht, gut, USB läuft halt noch, Firewire hat in etwa diese Zeit gehabt und auch dieser SETI-PIN-Connector. Das heißt, alles fällt nach 15 Jahren wieder raus und das sind ja auch alles so Schnittstellen ein bisschen schneller. Was ich sehr erstaunlich fand, ist, wie kurz VGA nur präsent war.
Das dachte ich auch gerade.
Auf dem Mac.
Ich meine, wenn du bedenkst, dass viele Business Notebooks heutzutage immer noch VGA haben, weil es ist ja auch, wenn du in die Meeting-Räume kommst, da ist ja auch oft VGA so die einzige funktionierende Alternative. Immer noch.
Das ändert sich aber.
Wir hatten vorher keinen VGA.
Ja, es gab doch diesen komischen Grafik-Connector von Apple.
Wie hieß der? Es gab mehrere Monitor-Stecker. An Macs. Es gab einen 15-poligen Monitor-Stecker. Da waren so diese ganzen ersten Farbmonitore von Mac 2.
Ich hatte doch meinen kleinen Mini-Sony-Monitor, der sehr uralte, den ich schon zu Amiga-Zeiten hatte. Hatt ich doch damals an meinem Power Mac dran. Das war doch VGA. Mein Power Mac ist von Mitte der 90er, und nicht von 2000, wo die da mit VGA loslegen.
Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich noch einen Adapter dafür gelötet habe. Von Apple-Grafik-Port auf VGA. Ganz viele Kabel, und irgendwo musste man dann irgendwas auf Masse ziehen, damit der richtig funktioniert.
Sync on Green, diesen Stecker meinst du? Sync on Green. Ja gut, aber das war ja trotzdem VGA.
Ja, aber kein VGA-Stecker in dem Sinne.
Also VGA, dieses Chart ist ein bisschen schlecht. Ich würde sagen, von 1998 bis 2008 gab es Apple-Produkte mit VGA.
Mein Power Mac, könnte ich hören, hat das auch schon, der war von 95.
Ja, aber der hatte wahrscheinlich keinen 25-poligen VGA-Stecker, ne?
Doch, drei reich, VGA, ich glaube schon.
Welcher Power Mac war denn das?
7500.
7500?
Also ich hatte den 7200, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass er das nicht hatte.
Power Mac 75, gucken wir mal.
Wir gucken einfach auf den Tracker, genau, weil Wikipedia, die wissen ja wieder nichts.
Display DB15.
Wie DB15?
Na, DB15 ist doch nicht VGA.
VGA war drei reich, ne?
Ja, 25-poliger.
Das ist ein neuner, der noch, was ist ich?
Noch eine Reihe extra hat, ne? Guck da erstmal nach, was VGA ist. VGA-Connector, wo geht's los?
Also wenn du jetzt beim VMAG4 zum Beispiel guckst, da steht einmal VGA und nicht DB15. Also VGA hat 15 Pins.
Und das ist auch hier, das ist DB15. Also das ist VGA's DB15. So, und jetzt gucken wir hier Mac Tracker.
Mac Tracker hat ziemlich komische Spezifikationen.
Hat das gar nicht aufgeführt. Ich glaube, hat den hier im Chat, wo ist denn der Chat? Kannst du nochmal zum Live scrollen? Der Chat guckt doch mal in den Chat.
Der Chat, ja, wieso scrollt der das Scheißteil nicht?
Weil es Slack ist.
Ja, Slack scrollt nicht. Ports, hier haben wir es doch. Video-Monitor, DV15.
Ich will meinen Power Mac gar nicht mehr. Power Mac enttäuscht doch da. So, 7500. Der da ist das. So, Schweigen im Kanal. Connections. Display, DB15. Ja, gut. Da steht jetzt nicht VGA, aber DB15 ist VGA. Und kann sein, dass man diesen Sync and Green Adapter braucht. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, aber ich würde das trotzdem VGA nennen.
Naja, da kamen im Prinzip VGA-Signale raus.
Nein, das ist kein VGA gewesen, mein Freund. DB15 meint wirklich einen zweireihigen breiten.
Ja, ich weiß. Nur, wie gesagt, da kamen im Prinzip VGA-Signale raus. Man brauchte nur ein paar Kabel richtig zusammenzulöten, dann hatte man einen Adapter, der funktioniert hat. Hab's ja gemacht.
Nein, das stimmt. Ich frage ja eigentlich oft auf diesen Aspekt hinaus. Wenn du mich jetzt gefragt hättest, wie lange halten Ports so und wie lange halten Standards, so 15 Jahre, ist das eigentlich viel? Oder ist das wenig?
Kommt drauf an.
Also ich meine, USB hat jetzt 16 Jahre sozusagen. Also in Max wohlgemerkt.
Also es kommt wirklich drauf an. Also entweder der Connector oder die Stecker-Art ist voll super, tut das, was sie soll und man hat auch gar keine Bedürfnisse, das doll zu ändern. Ein bisschen finde ich, dass bei dem Headphone Jack so ist das der Fall. Oder du hast halt irgendwie Floppy, was auch nicht wirklich ein Connector ist, sondern was anderes. Und das wird dann abgelöst von CD und das wird dann abgelöst von DVDs und die werden abgelöst von USB und USB ist irgendwann zu langsam und die werden abgelöst dann von USB-C und da kommt immer was Neues und was Schnelleres. Aber ehrlich gesagt, da Headphone-Jack analog ist, da muss nichts Schnelleres und Besseres kommen. Aber die werden den wahrscheinlich irgendwann abschaffen, weil halt kabellos ist angesagt. Und wenn du einen haben willst, kannst du ja einen USB-Dungel dranhängen. Das werden sie dir erzählen und die gibt es ja auch schon zu mass.
Ich habe hier jetzt meine Seite gefunden. Also das Ding an dem Apple-Connector war, dass ein Teil der Pins verwendet wurde, um zu codieren, was für ein Monitor dranhängt. Genau. Mit irgendwie verbunden und nach Masse gezogen und eine Diode in die Richtung oder eine Diode in die andere Richtung.
Und was war das für ein Segen?
Im Prinzip ja.
Ja, ganz praktisch war das ein Segen. Also ich meine, das war ja lange Zeit bei PCs immer auch noch so ein totales Elend, dass du einen Bildschirm angeschlossen hast und ein bisschen an deinem OS mal beigebracht hat. Was ist der jetzt tatsächlich aus dieser Grafikkarte rausspucken soll, damit da ein stabiles Bild bei rauskommt. Das hat ja auch gedauert. Das ist ja im Prinzip wie mit dem Drucken. Das hat ja auch irgendwie so ewig gedauert. Oder? Ich meine Drucken, das Thema hatten wir hier irgendwie vor der Sendung schon kurz.
Ja, apropos, ne.
Was denn?
Ich wollte eigentlich nicht auf einen Aufkleber drucken.
Oh, hatte ich noch so ein Hermes-Ding da drin? Ich hab das da nur eins reingelegt.
Da hat jetzt Roddy auch drauf gedruckt, auf den einen.
Guck mal, da posten Leute noch Telefone, die halt eben nicht die Kopfhörer-Standard-Klinke hatten, sondern die noch so einen komischen Adapter. Ich glaub, ich kann mich da auch noch erinnern. Ja, das war lange, lange Zeit so.
Ja, genau, das war echt lange so.
Und dann gab es irgendwann, welche Leute, die da Adapter gemacht haben, unten wieder eine Klinke dran waren, dass man dann wieder mit normalen Kopfhörern dran konnte.
Und dann hatten ja die Telefone lange Zeit erst mal zweieinhalb Klinke.
Apple waren, glaube ich, so ziemlich die ersten, die überhaupt mit dreieinhalb Klinke angefangen haben, oder?
Ja, das wäre cool gewesen, hätten sie noch mal gleich zweieinhalb gemacht.
Gab es vor dem iPhone ein populäres Telefon, das dreieinhalb Klinke hatte?
Bestimmt, es gab ja vorher schon welche, die Musik spielen.
Alles gab es schon, bevor Apple irgendwas gemacht hat.
Da bin ich mir nämlich noch relativ sicher, dass das eine echte Innovation war. Also Nokia hatte zweieinhalb und das war nicht...
Na gut, Apple hatte vorher den iPod lange Zeit und der hatte immer die dreieinhalb Klinke.
Klar, logisch. Ich meine, bei Apple hätte mich alles andere auch jetzt überrascht. Aber es war, sagen wir mal, im Telefonbereich, um da Audio rauszubekommen, gab es eigentlich wirklich nur diese komischen, fiesen Adapter-Teile.
Also hätte Apple mit dem iPod auf zweieinhalb gesetzt, dann würde es heutzutage gar nichts anderes mehr geben. So gesehen war das ein Fehler, dass sie das nicht gemacht haben.
Na ja, da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher.
Ich mir schon.
Ja, hätte, hätte Fahrrad-Gette. Aber damals war ja im Prinzip... Dreieinhalb Klinke war ja auch in der Apple-Welt schon lange etabliert vor dem iPod.
Ihr seid ja Fanboys, das ist ja schlimm, mit euch kann man ja nicht reden.
Also zum Beispiel das Nokia N95 hatte auch dreieinhalb Millimeter Klinke.
Wann war das nochmal?
Das war Ende der Siebziger. Kurz nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Das war Anfang 2007.
What?
So spät?
Naja, also ich meine...
Angekündigt Ende 2006.
Die dreieinhalber Klinke ist ja jetzt irgendwie auch keine wirklich neue Erfindung.
Das N95 war noch richtig gekrackt.
Gab es ja auch schon vor Mac.
Nein, ich sage ja nicht, dass es eine neue Erfindung war, sondern es war sagen wir mal sane, diesen Stecker zu nehmen und keinen anderen.
Na warum hat man nicht den kleineren genommen?
Weil, naja, aus Kompatibilitätsgründen. Es gab halt Abertausende Kopfhörer.
Du bist ein Fanboy, Tim, und zwar ganz schlimm. Hör mal zu, diese iPhones, ja, die haben irgendeinen. Du sollst ja zuhören.
Ich habe nur festgestellt, dass es Tausende an Abertausenden Modelle von Kopfhörern mit dreieinhalb, ich meine, dreieinhalb Zoll Klinke benutze ich schon seit Ever.
Ja, deswegen jetzt. Hörst du mal zu. Also.
Ich soll jetzt auch noch zuhören.
Ja, bitte. Die bei Apple haben sich irgendwann gedacht, Scheiß auf die Scheiß-Standards. Diese SIM-Karte ist uns fucking viel zu groß. Die machen jetzt mal eine Runde kleiner. Und ein paar Jahre später haben sie gedacht, weil es ja so gut geklappt hat, wir machen einfach, weil es uns Spaß macht, dann machen wir das jetzt nochmal kleiner und die Leute können nochmal mehr irgendwie SIM-Kartenlocher verkaufen. Also mit Standards irgendwie brechen, haben die gar kein Problem, wenn irgendwas durchzieht.
Das heißt, hätten die bei... Ne, ne. Die müssen nicht brechen. Apple ist inzwischen stark genug, dass die einfach genügend Leute haben, die sie in die Standards-Kommission schicken, die sagen, wir hätten das gerne kleiner.
Ja, ist doch das Gleiche am Ende.
Ja, ist es nicht.
Die Micro-SIM war schon standardisiert, als Apple angefangen hat.
Ja, aber die danach dann nicht mehr.
Die Nano-SIM.
Ja, also haben sie auch standardisiert, aber das haben sie halt selber.
Da sie auch drei GPP-Mitglied sind, sind sie natürlich hingegangen, haben sie gesagt, so guck mal, das ist alles viel sexier, und dann suchen sie einen zweiten, dann haben sie den Nokia dazu gebracht, der die Hand auch gehoben hat, dann ist die gut. Oder den.
Ja, den haben sie schon durchgedrückt.
Ja, was ich meine, ist, dass sie genug Marktmacht haben, um auch zweieinhalb durchzudrücken.
Ja, warum hätten sie das tun sollen?
Ja, warum haben sie das mit der SIM-Karte gemacht?
Das kann ja nicht folgen. Worauf willst du jetzt hinaus?
Ich will darauf hinaus, dass du was von Apple verteidigst, was...
Ich verteidige überhaupt nichts. Ich habe nur festgestellt, dass Kopfhörer 3,5 Millimeter war schon immer der Kopfhörerstandard.
Aber SIM war auch schon immer der Standard.
Ich habe in meinem Sony Walkman hatte ich so einen Kopfhörer.
6,3 war eigentlich immer der Kopfhörerstandard.
Nein, bei portablen Geräten in den 80ern hatte ich einen Sony Walkman, der erste Musikplayer von Nenzwerder.
Das heißt, die haben auch schon den Standard gebraucht?
Nein, es gab auch Sony Walkmans, die tatsächlich einen 6,3 hatten.
Das geht, einen Walkman hatte ich.
Auch schon in der Hand so ein Gerät. Also nicht selber besessen, aber in der Hand.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es das nicht gab. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass nahezu alle Sony Walkman haben eine dreieinhalb Millimeter-Klinke gehabt. Also alle Computer?
Also gerade die, die du zum Aufnehmen sehr gut verwendet hattest.
Jeder scheiß PC, wenn er überhaupt Sound hatte.
Es gab mal so eine Zeit der Sony Walkmans, die auch als Aufnahmegeräte benutzt wurden. Die hatten sowohl für Kopfhörer als auch für Mikro große Klinke. Ja, relativ robuste Teile. Und das Geile an den Teilen war, da war der Stecker nicht auf die Platine gelötet, sondern ins Gehäuse reingeschraubt. Und mit Kabeln an die Platine angeschlossen.
Das heißt, der ging auch nicht kaputt?
Genau.
Gut, es gibt aber auch 3,5 Zoll Stecker, wo man das auch so machen kann. Das ist jetzt eher so ein Implementationsdetail. Was ich aber sagen will, es hätte den kleineren Stecker genommen, hätte der sich bis heutzutage auch durchgesetzt. Wir feiern alles, was die bringen und sagen, ja, kleinere SIM-Karten, warum nicht? Voll geil, weil das ja Apple. Und bei 3,5 Zoll sagen wir, das ist schon richtig, weil warum sollten sie auch jemals mit dem was anderes nutzen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, worauf du jetzt hinausfällst. Ich habe überhaupt nichts gewertet. Ich habe nur gesagt, es war sinnvoll, mit dem iPhone auf 3,5 Klinke zu gehen, weil zu dem Zeitpunkt 2007 war das schon 20 Jahre lang der Standard. Länger.
Es findet sich, dass Apple sich noch nie gekümmert hat, was vorher Standard ist, sondern sie haben geguckt, was praktisch ist, und wenn sie das ändern wollen, ändern die das.
Wie mit der SIM.
Die war vorher auch ganz viele Jahre Standard. Wahrscheinlich auch 20.
Na ja, eine Weile lang war die ja Scheckkarten groß.
Alle SIMs, die sie bisher verwandelt haben, waren Standard. In den Pockys und so weiter.
Ein halb Zoll, der ist wahrscheinlich auch schon ganz lange Standard. Oder seit wann gibt es den?
Ja. Er ist ein Standard, aber im Sinne von er ist standardisiert, nicht im Sinne von er ist das Format, was du gemeinhin antriffst sozusagen.
An dem Fritz-Frohn ist glaube ich so ein Anschluss dran.
Welchen, in dem Teil hier, was ich hier habe, das Ding?
Das ist glaube ich ein zweieinhalber, irgendwie oben an der Ecke.
Nee, an der Seite.
An der Seite.
Das ist dreieinhalb. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Apple Kopfhörer-Mikro-Kombination geht, aber da gibt es ja auch so zwei oder drei Standards für... Ja, hören wirst du was, aber das Mikrofon geht ja nicht.
Ja, ich wollte nur kurz sicherstellen, dass es dreieinhalb ist. Dreieinhalb.
Na gut, ich dachte, es wären zweieinhalb. Ist ja auch egal.
Ja, es ist ja eh alles egal. Ich wollte nur darauf hinaus, Ports halten manchmal nicht so lange, wie man denkt.
Wie man es in Erinnerung hat.
Wie man es in Erinnerung hat. Mit der Ausnahme dieses Headphone-Jacks, der irgendjemand hier gerade so eine schöne alte Zeichnung gepostet, wann wurde der standardisiert, der ist irgendwie von vor 1900.
Patent, April 29.1919 steht da.
So alt ist der schon.
Ich glaube sogar noch älter.
Naja, das ist aber der Stecker, den sie in den Handvermittlungstelefonanlagen verwendet haben.
Ja, die gute Klinke. Also das ist schon...
Und das ist jetzt nicht dieser große, den du meintest, sondern wirklich der dreieinhalb Zoll.
Nee, nee, das ist schon der 6,3.
Jaja, der kleine...
6,3, wie viel ist das? Ein halbes Zoll oder so?
Klingt kein Stecker. Gucken wir doch mal hier. Ja, noch haben wir ja eigentlich gar keine.
Wo wolltest du denn drauf hinaus, dass gerüchtet wird, dass das nächste iPhone keinen mehr hat?
Nein, nein, ich wollte überhaupt nicht auf den Headphone-Stecker raus. Ich wollte eigentlich auf die anderen Ports hinaus. Und dass man sozusagen einfach, wenn man sich halt mal wirklich anschaut, wie langlebig ein Port ist. Weil ehrlich gesagt, den Headphone hatte ich jetzt gar nicht im Kopf. Mir ging es eher um die USBC-Debatte, die wir hatten und die Universalität irgendwie aller Schlitzstellen sozusagen.
Ich finde 15 Jahre auch völlig in Ordnung. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es möglich ist, einen Port zu designen, der länger als 15 Jahre hält. Weil die Entwicklung schreitet voran.
Wenn der Headphone-Jack jetzt weggeht und durch digital ersetzt wird, dann ist das wahrscheinlich so ein Schritt wie das Ersetzen von ISDN-Telefonie durch Internet-Telefonie.
Und Ethernet fehlt hier. Da hast du natürlich recht.
Wobei Ethernet ist ja kein Stacker, sondern der heißt natürlich RJ45.
Ja, wir wissen trotzdem, was gemeint ist.
Der fehlt, ne?
Also ich meine, thin Ethernet war natürlich auch nicht so.
Aber die Apple auch nicht so lange. Die hatten ja AOI vorher.
Richtig? Wann hatte denn Apple...
Mein Power Mac hatte noch AOI. Da musste man so einen Adapter ran machen.
Ja, einen Transziver ran machen.
Genau.
Für Fick Ethernet, ne?
Naja, so war das ja früher. Oder Ethernet.
Ja, mit externen Transzivern halt.
Weil Ethernet, was ja auch nicht alle wissen, ist ja eigentlich ein... Wie dick war das Kabel?
Noch.
Nicht armdick, aber so wie eine ordentliche Wurst, ne?
Wie eine ordentliche Wurst.
So eine Bratwurst.
Nee, Garden House.
Garden House?
Ja, also halb voll, dreiviertel Zoll Gardena.
Ne Wiener.
Ne Wiener ist zu dünn, eher Bockwurst.
Bockwurst. Aber das war doch schon das dünne.
Nein, das dünne war...
Das dünneste RG58-Kohax-Kabel, das schwarze.
Was so aussieht, wie das Antennenkabel beim Fernseher, aber eine andere Impedanz hat.
Genau. Viele Leute drauf reingefallen. Guck mal, ich hab das im Baumarkt gekriegt. Das ist viel billiger als ein scheiß teures Ethernet-Kabel. Na, mach mal Stecker dran. Viel Spaß.
Dann wechsle ich jetzt gerade irgendwas.
Das dicke war das erste, das gelbe. Das gelbe, das Original. Das war Bockwurst-dick.
Und da musste man noch so richtig mit einer Nadel rein...
Nee, du hattest diese Vampir-Transziver. Transziver mit einer Vampir-Klemme. Die waren so konstruiert, dass du sie draufgesetzt hast und dann mit so einer Art Immu-Schlüssel den eigentlichen Pin da reingedreht hast, der sich dann durch die äußere Umwandlung in ein Ding reingebissen hat und dann innen drin den Kern getroffen hat. Deswegen musste auch die Umwandlung starrende, feste Größe haben, sonst hätte nämlich diese Vampir-Geschichte nicht geklappt. Oder du hättest halt dauernd immer das Ding durchgebissen oder so. Das war halt so gemacht von der Mechanik her, dass sie genau nur auf den Core drauf gekommen ist.
Aber eigentlich geil. Ich meine, du brauchst noch nicht mal irgendwie einen speziellen Stecker und...
Nein, das hatte so andere Sorgen. Das ist halt ein Bussystem. Das war ja der beliebte Trick bei dem dünnen Zeug später, wo die mit diesen Bayonett-Verschlüssen, diesen B&C-Bayonett-Verschlüssen, dass du kannst halt das ganze Netz sabotieren, indem du halt irgendwo einen aufgemacht hast oder einen Entwiderstand abgemacht hast. Und dann konntest du dem Admin zusehen, wie er durchs ganze Haus rennt und geguckt hat, wo jetzt die Kupplung offenbar oder welcher Entwiderstand gefehlt hat oder so. Das war sehr lustig. Also war nicht so richtig.
Naja, du musstest einen Abschlusswiderstand mit dem gleichen Wellenwiderstand haben.
50 Ohm. Dann gab es ja diese komischen T-Stücke. Dann hatten die Leute unter den Schreibtischen, dann haben die Leute neben ihrem Desktop-PC, dann haben sie herumgefüßelt und haben das T-Stück abgetreten. Oder einen von diesen B&C-Dingern, die ließen sich ja einfach abschnippen. War dann offen und dann ging das ganze Netz nicht mehr.
Weil du natürlich eine Reflektion hattest an der Stelle. Dadurch, dass der Wellenwiderstand nicht stimmt.
93 auf der Heu hatten die so ein Netzwerk.
Ja, das stimmt. Ein Quarks-Jahrkabel von Zelt zu Zelt.
Und im Haupthack-Center. Und alles, wie alle tausend Leute, mit zwei ESD-Inleitungen versorgt, glaube ich.
Ja, das ging damals noch. Das war noch pre-Netflix.
Na gut, wir müssen nicht weiter über Ayo-Ports reden. Ich wollte noch mal eine kurze Experience mitteilen, die Clemens schon längst mitgeteilt hat. Aber jetzt hatte ich das auch mal.
Ach, Apfelzahl.
Podcast-Kollege Felix Bezin hat einen Artikel auf Zeit online veröffentlicht, wo er einen Trick vermittelt hat, wie man sich ApplePay so freischalten kann, dass man auch hier in Deutschland bezahlen kann, mit Umwegen. Ich fasse es mal kurz zusammen. Es gibt einen virtuellen Kreditkartenanbieter, Boon.
Das ist doch ein Englischer Kreditkartenanbieter.
Du weißt schon, dass Boon auch das Wort für Noob ist? Wirklich? Also in World of Warcraft wurden die Anfangs immer Noob genannt, die Anfänger. Weil das natürlich nicht mehr irgendwann elite genug war, haben sie immer Boon zu den Anfängern gesagt, damit die das auch nicht so peilen.
Okay, das war ein unnützes Wissen, was ich noch nicht hatte.
Unnützes Wissen für zwei Jahre.
Die heißt doch nicht umsonst so.
Nee, ist gut, ist super. Also heißt Boon. Und im Prinzip kannst du dir da per App eine Kreditkarte klicken. Nur, dass du die halt nicht in Form von einer Karte, einer physikatischen Karte, sondern eben so eine, die quasi nur im Netz, in der Cloud existiert. Die aber dann trotzdem nach außen hin, als Mastercard.
Weil die auch nur Menace-Mittel sind.
Genau, also wie eine Bank hier in Deutschland Mastercards an dich ausgeben kann, geben die halt auch Mastercards an dich aus, aber eben nur elektronisch. Und sie sind dann halt auch mit ihrer App in UK, als ApplePay, compatible, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob die jetzt eigentlich in irgendeiner Form einen Deal haben müssen. Jetzt muss ich mir überlegen, sie sind das ausgebende Institut für die Kreditkarte, also damit quasi der Transaktionspartner von Apple, wenn man ApplePay macht, also im Prinzip haben die einen Deal mit Apple, dass sie auch ApplePay unterstützen. So wie das andere Banken mit normalen Konten eben auch machen und deren Karten.
Okay, dann kurze Zwischenfrage. Wenn du das nur als virtuelle Karte hast, und das iPhone hast du ja auch, ApplePay kann, wie scanne ich dann die Karte, wenn ich keine habe?
Pass auf, also was du machen musst, ist erstens, du musst jetzt erstmal, wenn du das jetzt machen willst, dann musst du erstmal in deine Settings gehen und deine App Store, also du brauchst erstmal eine neue Apple ID, eine zusätzliche.
Eine Fake nur dafür erst mal.
Die nur für den UK-Store ist. Die trägst du dann da ein und sagst hier UK-Store, also erzeugst die einmal im UK-Store, trägst den auf deinem Telefon ein, schmeißt also die andere kurz beiseite, lockst dich quasi in den UK-App Store ein, dann kannst du da mit der Apple ID diese App runterladen. Danach kannst du das aber auch schon wieder zurück ändern. Also nur für diesen Download-Vorgang, um diese App zu bekommen. Dann musst du allerdings auch nochmal in deine Settings gehen und deine Region auf UK umstellen.
Weil da so eine Region-Sperre drin ist?
Genau, weil da so eine Region-Sperre drin ist. Das gilt aber mehr für das iOS selber und für diese Wallet. Dann startest du irgendwie diese App und dann musst du halt irgendwie eine Adresse in UK angeben. Da geben die sich aber irgendwie mit allem zufrieden offenbar. Ich hab da sowas halt...
Downing Street 10 oder was?
Genau, da dürfte glaube ich schon eine ganze Menge sein. Oder gibst die Adresse von Boris Johnson an.
Unseren zukünftigen Außenminister.
Dem neuen Außenminister.
Geht vorwärts da, wir merken.
Die müssen gegen die Amis anstinken. Wenn die Amis jetzt mit Trump als Präsident vorlegen, müssen die den Briten hinterher.
The US has a Trump card.
Vielleicht wird Trump ja auch Außenminister.
Ja, und die haben den längsten Johnson. Also, dann legst du da quasi in dieser Boon-App einen Account an und wirst dann quasi Kreditkartenkunde. Jetzt ist das so eine Kreditkarte, die natürlich nicht Kreditkarte, sondern eigentlich eine Debitkarte ist. Das heißt, du kannst damit nur ausgehen, was da auch drauf ist. Das heißt, das ist quasi so ein Konto, was du aufladen kannst. Und das kannst du halt entweder über eine andere Kreditkarte aufladen. Das geht dann sofort.
Innerhalb der App, oder wie geht das?
Ja, innerhalb der App. Also du machst quasi eine Kreditkartenzahlung auf dieses Konto. Kannst du es auch über SEPA machen, was den Vorteil hat, dass es halt nichts kostet, das Aufladen über SEPA. Aber den Nachteil hat, dass es halt länger dauert. Und wenn man dann so jetzt ausprobieren, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, dann muss man natürlich sofort nochmal Gebühren und nochmal Gebühren aufwerfen. Aber es ist ja egal, es geht ja erstmal darum, dass es irgendwie funktioniert. Hab ich dann gemacht, hab da irgendwie 50 Pfund drauf geworfen.
Dann...
Ist das shoppen gegangen?
Nein, nein, jetzt ist es ja noch nicht Apple Pay. Jetzt ist es ja zunächst einmal nur eine App. Ich hab halt jetzt in irgendeiner englischen App bei einem englischen Provider, der mir jede Adresse glaubt, ein Konto angelegt und denen da auch noch Geld gegeben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was ist denn hier mit Anti-Terror-Fu-Bar?
Scheiß drauf, weiß ich, keine Ahnung.
Also an deiner Stelle würde ich nicht mehr versuchen zu fliegen.
Weil ich jetzt Apple Pay benutze oder was?
Weil du Geld wäscht.
Ach, ich habe eh schon mit dem Land gebrochen. Das ist mir egal. Die werden jetzt eh...
Du hast ins Land gebrochen.
Das bestimmt auch. Das geht bei so einem englischen Papp schnell.
Voll ins Land gebrochen.
Du hast jetzt 50 Pfund drauf, aber du hast noch kein Apple Pay.
Genau. Das ist aber jetzt relativ einfach zu machen. Jetzt stellst du dein Telefon auf UK-Region um.
Ja, haben wir ja schon eigentlich.
Jetzt wird alles relevant. Du kannst vorher boonen, die App und so weiter an deinem Konto einrichten. Wenn du das dann alles gemacht hast, dann spielst du dann, jetzt bist du mal ein UK-Phone, dann bootet das neu, startet neu, was auch immer, und dann taucht da ein Add to Wallet auf. Das heißt, in der App hast du dann so einen Button, der sagt so, ja, jetzt füge ich quasi diese Kreditkarte per API, lokal, dem ApplePay.
Verstehe, man muss kein Bild machen, weil es geht über die App.
Genau. Und das machst du dann, und dann hast du das Ding da in deinem ApplePay und kannst mit dem iPhone bezahlen.
Kannst du dann wieder zurück auf deuterische?
Genau, jetzt kannst du aber alles wieder zurückstellen, kannst deine original Apple ID wieder benutzen, kannst aber weiterhin diese Boon-App noch auch nutzen, obwohl du die Apple ID wieder umgestellt hast. Und kannst die Apple ID eigentlich die alte vergessen.
Genau, diese Apple ID brauchst du nur zum Runterladen der App und das Regionsumstellen brauchst du nur zum Hinzufügen zur Wallet. Beziehungsweise nicht, dass der Button kommt, sondern dass der Button dann auch Erfolg hat. Kannst du danach aber beides immer wieder jeweils zurückstellen und wenn du die mit der Apple Watch bezahlen willst, dann derselbe Spaß in der Watch-App noch einmal auch wieder UK-Regionen konfigurieren und dann kannst du in der Boon-App auch das zur Watch-App hinzufügen. Also du kannst aus der iPhone-App Apple Pay auf der Watch machen. Also frag dich vorher, wo willst du es drauf haben, iPhone oder Watch? Und dann haltest du es auf der Watch. So, und das habe ich dann alles gemacht. Und dann bin ich irgendwie zu Rossmann gelatscht und konnte tatsächlich mir irgendwie einen Satz Zahnbürsten und Zahnpasta kaufen mit meiner Uhr. Und das war schon irgendwie wieder so ein 21. Jahrhundert-Moment. So ein Moment der Dekadenz zu werden.
Und wie schnell geht das so? Also beim Bezahlen im Room 77 mit Bitcoins macht die Bedienung, tippt die Summe in den QR-Code, ich halte es drauf und es dauert ein, zwei Sekunden und dann sagt sie okay.
Ja, ich sage einfach bezahlen und das ist im Prinzip, ich muss gar nichts Besonderes sagen, es ist einfach der normale EC-Kartenbezahl-Modus.
Man muss sagen, ich will mit Karte zerführen, damit sie das zu diesem Terminal schickt. Und dann steckt man nicht seine EC-Karte rein, sondern du sagst dann auf deine Uhr, okay.
Genau, ich habe die Uhr da so direkt drauf. Also ich habe es vorher in einem anderen Ladeausbruch, da hat es nicht funktioniert, da wusste ich aber nicht so richtig, was Sache war, vielleicht war ich nicht nahe genug dran, keine Ahnung, habe da noch nicht so viel Erfahrung mit. Da habe ich dann einfach die Uhr direkt auf das Gerät gehalten, also quasi so face-on, und dann drückst du halt einfach Doppelklick an diesem Side-Button und es macht so brrrrm, fertig.
du drückst es erst und dann...
Ja genau, also Doppelklick, dann ist es so aktiv, und dann hältst du es dran und macht es kurz brrrrm an deinem Arm.
Das war es auch schon.
Bling, und...
Und dann hast du so rrrrrt, fertig.
Genau, und das coole war, also erstmal wurde es auch, sagen wir mal, fraglos akzeptiert, weil ich meine, die kriegen da auf ihrer Kasse ja nichts anderes als hat funktioniert. Dann kümmern die sich nicht drum, wie das jetzt technisch funktioniert hat. Und dann hatte ich in der Boon-App auch sofort danach dieses Payment. Man ist ja mal bei Bezahlen immer dran gewohnt, dass man dann irgendwie nächste Woche ein Kontoaussuch kriegt, wo das dann drauf steht oder so. Nee, hier hatte ich das irgendwie sofort. Hatte dann halt irgendwie so einen Pfundbetrag, der mir von meinem Pfundkonto abgezogen wurde. Dann habe ich den mal schnell irgendwie bei Google in den aktuellen Umrechnungskurs umgestellt. Und obwohl da Transaktionsgebühren drauf sind, nämlich in dem Fall da Auslandszahlungen, 1,25 Prozent, also schon recht happig, hatte ich nach Umrechnungskurs 10,52 Euro bezahlt. Und auf der Rechnung stand aber 10,58. Ich will mir ja gespart, weil das hängt ja davon ab, wie viel ich meine 50 Pfund dann da hingebracht habe, Wechselkursverluste, lalala, und dann haben sie mir da auch nochmal Brexit und haben sie mir auch nochmal einen Pfund geklaut und keine Ahnung.
Die Brexit-Kursverluste?
Also darum geht es mir jetzt auch gar nicht. Es ist ja sozusagen auch ein bisschen gaga. Ich könnte zwar auf diesem Buhn jetzt auch noch so ein Auto top up konfigurieren von meiner Kreditkarte, teuer, teuer sozusagen. Also ich könnte mir das so einstellen, dass ich im Prinzip immer, wenn ich gerade kein Bargeld dabei habe, jetzt mit der Uhr hier bezahlen kann, so es denn ein kontaktloses Terminal gibt, was auch irgendwie korrekt angebunden ist. Ja, aber es ist gar nicht so oft, es ist nicht so einfach zu erkennen, ob es das gibt. Teilweise wissen die das nicht.
Es steht nicht dran. Du kennst aber irgendwann diese Terminals. Du erkennst die WD-Aussehen. Diese Terminals, das kann das und das andere kann das nicht. Und fertig. Ich hatte neulich mal einen interessanten Fall in Hannover.
McDonald's soll eigentlich auch dazugehören.
Hab ich noch nicht auswählen. Bei McDonald's gehe ich aber gut.
Ja, aber da hast du dann irgendwie... Dennis auf Fliegenjagd. Er ist tot jetzt.
Und der Fenster ist offen.
Elements of computing systems building a modern computer from first.
Auf meinem tollen Buch hat er jetzt einen Fliegenschiss draufgemacht.
Nein.
Das darfst du ablegnen.
Das ist eine zerquetschte Fliege.
Das war ein Geschenk, Mann.
Toll, Roddy. Für dich mache ich die tot und dann reitest du mich so von hinten rein. Für dich kille ich mal noch eine Fliege.
Ich mache das Buch wieder sauber, weil du die Fliege so heldenhaft erlegt hast.
In Hannover sollte ich mal einen Zettel unterschreiben, weil die Kassiererin meinte, sie kannte es nicht. Ich machte dann so ein Pling mit der Uhr. Kasse sagte alles okay und ich wollte abdacken. Sie sagten, sie müssten hier noch unterschreiben. Ich musste da ja nichts unterschreiben. Wo soll ich denn da was unterschreiben? Ich sagte, da steht ja noch nicht mal Unterschrift. Weil diese Apple-Zeuge anonymisiert wird. Das heißt, der Wender kriegt im Gegensatz zu einer Kreditkarte nicht meinen Namen oder irgendwas. Da steht dann irgendwo mein Name. Wo soll ich da irgendwas unterschreiben? Doch, ich soll mal sicherheitshalber. Dann habe ich drei Kreuze hin gemacht. Da hat sie mich hingekickt und dann bin ich gegangen.
Für was für eine Summe?
Das war im Zoo in Hannover. Haben wir da was gegessen zu dritt? Keine Ahnung. Das waren 20 Euro oder so drei Würste. Und da noch ein Nachtisch oder ein Getränk oder so.
PayPal hat halt auch deine Unterschrift anonymisiert. Da hat doch mal jemand, irgendwie gab es noch mal vor Jahren, hat doch mal jemand ausprobiert, auf Kreditkartenabrechnungen zu unterschreiben, was man da eigentlich... Der ging davon aus, niemand guckt sich an, wie man eigentlich unterschreibt auf der Kreditkartenabrechnung. Und hat halt über Monate hinweg immer mit immer abstruseren Namen unterschrieben. Und am Ende ist er dazu übergegangen, kleine Bilder zu malen, statt zu unterschreiben. Es ist nie irgendetwas mit Fragen gestellt worden.
Ja, ist doch die Frage, was ist deine Unterschrift?
Bei dieser alten Unterschrift war ja dein Merchant verpflichtet, deine Karte anzugucken und die Unterschrift zu vergleichen.
Macht auch niemand an diesen Tankstellen, wo sie ja ganz oft wieder jetzt mit Unterschrift machen, weil sie dann irgendwie einen Prozent sparen, fangen sie wieder damit an, ne? Da guckt auch keiner nach.
Dann mache ich immer wieder vorher an mit Pin-Zahlen. Und dann gibt es halt diese Fuzzies, die sagen, scheißegal, ich mache das, was die Kasse immer macht. Dann kommt dieser Streifen raus, legen sie mit dem Unterschreiben hin. Dann drehe ich den um, das steht drauf, auf dem Kleingedruckten hintenrum steht drauf. Wenn sie das so nicht wollen, können sie auch sagen, dass sie mit Pin bezahlen möchten. Steht drauf hinten. Dann halte ich ihm das Ding wieder ins Gesicht, sage so, Alter, das machst du jetzt nochmal, unterschreib dir den Zettel nicht. Hab mir gesagt, ich will mit Pin zahlen, und das steht auf dem Zettel drauf.
Warte mal, auf welchem Zettel steht es drauf?
Wenn du nicht mit Pin zahlst, dann druckt der die Kasse einen Zettel aus, den du unterschreiben sollst. Wenn du diesen Zettel auch mal umdrehst, da steht da hinten immer so dieser in hellgrau auf weiß, diese lalala hiermit akzeptiere ich das, meine Daten gespeichert, tralalala, pipapo. Und einer der letzten Sätze da unten ist drauf, wenn sie das so nicht wollen, dann können sie auch ansagen, dass sie bitte mit Pin zahlen. Steht da unten drauf. Dann nimmst du das, drückst es dem Kassierer ins Gesicht, der kriegt natürlich erst mal Pickel, weil hinter dir noch 20 andere Leute stehen und sein Chef hat ihnen das nur so gezeigt, aber er hat dir vorher gesagt, er will mit Pin zahlen. Er hat gesagt, das immer vorher an. Und warum wollen die überhaupt Unterschriften haben?
Ich verstehe das überhaupt nicht.
Das ist billiger.
Was? Für die? Nein, pass auf, manche dieser Unterschriften sind dann nämlich nicht, also insbesondere wie Vandit. Nein, die können das manchmal dann auch als Lastschrift machen. Das ist dann eine andere Einzugsform als Bezahlung per Kreditkarte. Sondern du willest dann in so einer Art Lastschrift-Einzug oder so etwas ein mit dem Zettel. Deswegen ist das aus irgendwelchen Fachszenen, da muss der Chat jetzt mal weiterhelfen, bestimmt in welche Banker oder Ex-Banker oder sonst und was die uns dazu hören, die uns das mal erklären können, was das soll oder warum das billiger ist, warum das mit Unterschrift billiger ist als mit Pin.
Das ist so ganz, wenn du oft unterwegs bist und du bist bei einer Tankstelle, du warst da noch nie, dann kommt es mit Pin. Dann fährst du auf der Rückfahrt an der gleichen Tankstelle vorbei, dann kennen die dich irgendwie schon anscheinend und dann musst du plötzlich unterschreiben, weil du bist ja anscheinend einigermaßen sicher und deswegen können sie uns ein paar Cent sparen.
Nein, manche machen das auch random. Die Systeme bieten alle an, dass man ansagen kann, was der Kunde möchte. Dann müssen halt eine Taste mehr drücken. Diese Zeit hatten sie in ihrer Schulung nicht. Also die armen Kassierer müssen dann schon immer ein bisschen drunter leiden, aber, Entschuldigung, möchte trotzdem nur mit PIN bezahlen. Möchte ich keine Unterschrift dafür leisten. Und guck auf den Zettel hinten drauf. Da steht drauf, wenn sie das so nicht wollen, können sie auch ansagen, dass sie mit PIN bezahlen können.
Ich verstehe, mein Hirn setzt gerade aus. Warum ist denn das billiger für den Händler?
Da schreibt jemand, bei PIN ist Zahlung garantiert deshalb teurer.
Ohne Prüfung online, ja, deswegen. Die Online-Prüfung kostet halt was. Sozusagen, die schalten auf ein bisschen unsicherer, um ein paar Cent zu sparen.
Die PIN ist gar... Das heißt, die Händler sind nicht bereit, dafür Geld auszugeben, dass sie sicher auch ihr Geld kriegen?
Diese Unterschrift, das Lastschrift, dauert länger, bei PIN ist es online und die Zahlung geht mehr oder weniger.
Anscheinend wird zu wenig doch mit Karten beschissen, dass die wieder mit so einem Scheiß anfangen. Und irgendwann dreht sich das Spiel wieder um, weil die merken, es ist ja ganz oft wieder mit Unterschrift in letzter Zeit, dann wird der Betrug wieder sich erhöhen und dann werden sie es wieder zurücknehmen.
Also hier steht, die nachträgliche Unterschriftenprüfung ist toll.
Ja, wird ja nicht immer geprüft. Die wird ja nur bei Disput geprüft. Ansonsten kannst du ein Männchen draufmalen. Die Tüber ist gesagt, kannst du ein Männchen draufmalen. Das wird ja keine Sau, solange du die Abruhung nicht anzweifelst.
Jedenfalls war ich mal bei IKEA und hatte eine neue EC-Karte und hatte den nicht unterschrieben und wollte damit bezahlen. Und dann guckte die Tante da drauf und meinte, die ist ja nicht unterschrieben. Da meinte ich, ist ja egal, ist ja mit PIN. Ne, die müsste aber unterschrieben sein. Dann unterschreibe ich die jetzt. Ne, das geht nicht und wollte mir die Karte wegnehmen. Und dann meinte ich, das geht gar nicht. Da habe ich mich mit der bisschen rumgeärgert, habe meine Karte wiederbekommen und habe gesagt, hier ist mir egal, ich zahle jetzt bar. Aber die wollte tatsächlich die Karte einziehen. Und ich habe gesagt, wenn sie das macht, rufe ich die Polizei. Aber dazu ist nicht gekommen. Aber eigentlich hätte man das noch durchziehen müssen. Aber ich habe so einen Halt und ich habe selten einen Halt.
Und ich habe selten einen Halt.
Sendenziebel Marker.
Können wir jetzt noch aufreden. Also rechtlich gesehen würde ich sagen, die darf das überhaupt gar nicht.
Vor allem die interessante Frage ist doch, warum ist es schlechter, wenn du die EC-Karte vor ihren Augen unterschreibst, als wenn du es draußen vor dem Laden machst?
Ja, habe ich ja auch gesagt. Wenn die so weit denken würden, hätten sie vielleicht auch einen anderen Job. Das habe ich hier so nicht gesagt. Übrigens mit diesen Kartengeschichten, so einfach ist das übrigens nicht. Das hängt von dem jeweiligen Kartentyp ab. In der Regel ist es so, dass die Banken oder die ausstellenden Banken ein Eigentum... die schenken dir die Karte nicht, sondern das ist unsere Karte, die wir dir leihen. Das heißt, die bleibt im Eigentum der Bank.
Ja, das heißt, sie kann mich doch gar nicht einziehen.
Und wenn zum Beispiel ihr Computersystem der Kassiererin sagt, diese Karte ist gesperrt, einziehen, dann ist in dem Moment die Kassiererin Erfüllungsgehilfen der Bank, die dann sagt, ich hier für meine Bank, ich bin beauftragt worden von der Bank, die Karte, die ihr gehört, die ihr wegzunehmen.
Jeder Schnösel ist Erfüllungsgehilfe?
Nein, nicht jeder Schnösel, der angewiesen wird von deiner Bank. Sie kann nicht selber entscheiden, auch die Unterschrift ist im Blau, die gefällt mir nicht, ich kenne keine Unterschrift.
Das heißt, wenn im Display kommt, sie soll die einziehen? Das kommt ja nicht, wenn ich nicht unterschrieben habe.
Natürlich nicht, da ist sie schon ein bisschen über ihr Ding hinausgesprungen. Aber rein von der Rechtslage her, von wegen Polizei ist, wenn die Kassierungen eine Anweisung kriegen, von der Bank, wenn die geklaut ist, dann steht, Achtung, geklaut, bitte einziehen, dann ja. Die Bank sagt, das ist meine Karte, die leihen wir dir nur.
War aber bei mir nicht der Fall, war nur nicht unterschrieben, war nagelneue Per-Post gekommen.
Naja, also so viel zum Bezahlen. Jüngst ging es ja so ein bisschen hin und her noch an den Medien, wer denn nun eigentlich schuld ist, daran, dass wir noch kein ApplePay in Deutschland haben.
Fingerpointing galore.
Ja, Fingerpointing galore. Am Anfang meinte ja so, es gab ja diese komische Petition, die irgendjemand losgetreten hat, mit so, wir müssen ja jetzt mal eine Petition starten, wo ich mir auch dachte, so, mhhh. Ja, also vor allem, also ich hätte ja jetzt nichts dagegen gehabt, wenn jetzt Leute deswegen versuchen, auf irgendeine Seite Druck auszuüben. Die Frage ist nur, gab es überhaupt zuverlässige Informationen darüber, auf wen jetzt man Druck ausüben soll? Weil kann ja auch sein, dass man diese Petition Apple irgendwie entgegenkommen lassen muss. Also es gab so die Annahme, dass es an Banken lag und es gab dann auch eine Anfrage, das haben wir glaube ich letztes Mal schon, wo irgendein Bankenverband, weiß ich mal ganz genau, meinte jetzt so, ja, nee, das ist bei uns kein Thema. Aber ich hatte eher so den Eindruck, die haben überhaupt nicht, also die Person, die in dem Moment vielleicht mit dem Fall beschäftigt war, wusste gar nicht so richtig, worum es ging. Das kann ich mir auch kurz vorstellen.
Die Sparkassen haben aber schon vor Jahren durchblicken lassen, dass sie das eigentlich gerne hätten.
Ja, und ehrlich gesagt, ich sehe auch überhaupt keinen Grund, warum jetzt eine Bank eigentlich Apple Pay nicht unterstützen sollte.
Das sei denn, Apple will zu viel Geld. Oder zu viel Einfluss. Und die Banken haben das Gefühl, ihnen nimmt jetzt jemand die SMS weg.
Ne, die nehmen dir die Kundendaten weg. Durch diese ganze Anonymisierung.
Der Bank nicht, die kriegt es ja.
Die kriegen aber die Merchant-Informationen nicht mehr notwendigerweise, oder? Nein, der Merchant kriegt die Information nicht mehr.
Aber ist ja der Bank egal.
Ja, aber nicht vielleicht dem Dienstleister für den Merchant. Die Bank des Merchants. Die Bank des Händlers.
Die spielt ja überhaupt keine Rolle.
Natürlich spielt die eine Rolle. Weil doch, das ist der Dienstleister, der dem Händler der Terminal zur Verfügung stellt.
Ja, aber das ist ja eine nachgelagerte Entscheidung. Zunächst einmal muss ja die Bank mit Apple einen Vertrag machen.
Auf der Kundenseite.
Genau, dass Kunden dieser Bank mit einem bestimmten Zahlungsmedium sich darüber identifizieren und eine Zahlung auslösen können über diesen ApplePay-Weg. Was ja Apple mittlerweile mit tausenden Banken in den USA hat und mit vielen in den UK und ein paar andere Länder. Schweiz hat jetzt gerade noch gestartet. Und das ändert ja, sagen wir mal, für die Bank im Prinzip nichts. Apple nimmt natürlich ein 0,0, keine Ahnung, wer auch immer der Meinung ist, feste Informationen darüber zu haben, wie viel Apple nimmt. Also sie nehmen halt irgendeinen Teil, tauschen das aber eben ein gegen eine relativ hohe Fraudresistance. Weil eine Apple-Pay-Zahlung, also habe ich jetzt bisher noch kein überzeugendes Angriffsmodell gesehen, wie man dem sozusagen was, also das ist deutlich besser abgesichert als PIN, deutlich besser abgesichert als Unterschrift und schon gar kein Vergleich mit Kreditkarte, mit irgendwie geben sie die drei Zahlen, die auf der Rückseite stehen.
Es ist Two Factor, es ist Wissen und Haben.
Genau, und mit Touch ID und Pipapo und es ist sicher in dem Gerät und es kommt da irgendwie nie raus und es gibt keine Malware, die das irgendwie jemals da rausgeprokelt hat. So ist es halt einfach derzeit noch nicht. Aber bei Android gab es das jetzt mit ohne Secure Element, sind diese Informationen schon mal abhanden gekommen, weil lag im RAM, beim iPhone liegt es halt nicht im RAM und bei der Watch werden wir ja sehen, wie lange es hält, aber bisher ist das für mich bisher das überzeugendste und sicherste Konzept, was ich so für bei Payment gesehen habe, was dazu eben auch noch kompatibel ist mit dem normalen Händlerweg. So und der Händler muss natürlich die technischen Voraussetzungen dafür haben. Klar, kontaktloses Payment. Ich weiß nicht, ob die irgendeine Möglichkeit haben, ApplePay zu verhindern.
Das sieht ja erstmal aus wie eine normale Kreditkarte.
Das sieht erstmal aus wie eine normale Karte.
Der Anbieter, also der Terminal wird das nicht rausfinden können, aber der Anbieter dahinter könnte ja sagen, sie haben bestimmte Nummernkreise. Apple hat ja nur bestimmte Nummernkreise, aus denen sie ihre Pools bilden für diese Abrechnungsdinger. Und dass sie sagen, ja das ist alles Apple Pay, das blocken wir jetzt vielleicht. Das hat sich aber Apple auf der anderen Seite sicherlich gegenüber den Zahlungssystemanbietern auch abgesichert vertraglich. Du kannst ja auch nicht einfach hingehen und sagen, auch dieser Kreditkarten-Nummernkreis ist jetzt meiner, den akzeptiert er mal bitte alle, sondern du kriegst, das gibt ja da so Konsortien, die weisen dir diese Nummernkreise zu und dann unterschreibst du hier und da und dort, und Verträge und lalala, ist so wie Roaming im Internet. Da kannst du auch nicht einfach ausknipsen, sondern dann musst du halt erstmal einen Vertrag verletzen und dann kannst du das abknipsen. Ja, aber technisch wäre das das Möglichste zu identifizieren.
Gut, also für mich stellt sich das derzeit so da. Ich hab so den Eindruck, Apple hat irgendwie aus welchen Gründen auch immer noch nicht diesen Schritt vollzogen, dass sie ApplePay in Deutschland einführen. Und es kann sein, dass sie sich mit den Banken noch nicht grün geworden sind über die Beteiligung. Es kann sein, dass sie noch nicht genug haben, dass es irgendwelche Major-Player gibt, die sie von Anfang an gerne im Boot hätten, damit sie da überzeugend starten können. Weil nur mit Sparkassen starten in Deutschland ist nicht nichts. Aber ich glaube, sowas wie Deutsche Bank und Commerzbank und so weiter will man halt irgendwie noch mit dabei haben. So, würde mich zumindest jetzt nicht überraschen, wenn sie so einen Anspruch hätten. Um einfach gleich von vornherein sagen zu können, wir haben eigentlich gut was abgedeckt.
Ja, aber langsam ist es ein bisschen überreizt von, wir schieben das hier ein bisschen auf die lange Bank. Ich meine, der Deutsche Markt ist jetzt auch nicht gerade klein, oder?
Ja, er ist nicht klein, aber es ist vielleicht schwierig, mit den Banken klarzukommen.
Ja, aber dann fängt man halt mit ein, zwei Banken weg.
Ja, aber ich glaube, wenn sie wirklich einen Vertrag mit der Sparkasse, also mit allen Sparkassen machen könnten, dann hätten sie wirklich einen guten Fuß im Markt. Also da kann sich dann letzten Endes auch eine Deutsche Bank und so weiter und die Commerzbank nur schwer gegen wehren, glaube ich.
Deren Problem wird eher dahingehend gehen, dass sie immer noch davon träumen, dass sie was Vergleichbares oder was Vergleichbares selber anbieten und diese 0, tralala oder die 1, tralala Prozent noch selber einstreichen. Und wenn sie jetzt den Damm aufmachen, die Leute jetzt alle mit ApplePay bezahlen, dann kommen sie mit ihrem Commerzbank-Pay oder Deutsche Bank-Pay. Ja, trotzdem träumen die davon, dass das ihr Markt ist. Ihr Markt und ihre Kunden. Es ist genauso wie vorhin besprochen, die Telekom-Leute, die tatenlos zusehen müssen, dass solche Buden wie WhatsApp ihnen die ganzen Kunden abgreifen und da auch stinkig drüber sind, weil sie am liebsten ihr Join vermarkten können, dass sie nochmal eine Message für 39 Cent verkaufen können. Das sind völlig absurde Träume, aber da träumen die immer noch.
Also was ich mir vorstellen kann, ist, dass es für das andere kontaktlose Zahlen halt so einen bankenübergreifenden Konsortiumsvertrag gibt und in dem eventuell drinsteht, wenn du hier mitmachst, darfst du O-Port-Diskussion nicht mitmachen. Und das jetzt ein...
Ja, aber das internationale Zeug, da gibt es gar keine Apple-Zeugs, schon gar nicht in den UK oder in der Schweiz.
Nö, das kann ja durchaus ein deutsches Ding sein und das kann durchaus dazu führen, dass es keine große Bank gibt in Deutschland, die wagt, dagegen aufzubegehren, weil sie eventuell dann halt das restliche kontaktlose Zahlen verlieren.
Aber theoretisch müssten wir ja auch über die EU-Schiene rangehen können. Leider, dass die Briten da die ersten sind, ist schon ein bisschen nervig. Aber ansonsten kann man ja über die Harmonisierung des europäischen Binnenmarktes nachgehen. Das heißt, wenn irgendein europäischer Zahlungsanbieter, der jetzt mal aus dem Kniff kommt, kann man ja über diese EU-Schiene hingehen und sagen, das wollen wir bitte schön auch in den anderen EU-Unternehmen haben.
Großbritannien und Schweiz, Pech gehabt.
Schweiz ist nicht EU.
Großbritannien im Prinzip auch nicht mehr.
Großbritannien interessiert keine Sorgen mehr. Mit denen redet keiner mehr in Brüssel von daher. Ja, wir warten mal. Ich glaube, es gibt ja den nächsten Unterhaus in Schweden oder so.
Nur mit der Viking Express. Also da haben sie es aus. Ja, keine Ahnung. Also steckste nicht drin.
Aber wer immerhin Euro marktet, heißt, wenn man da rüber rankäme, dann würdest du nicht diesen Umweg über Pfund machen mit Wechselkurs und Lada und Auslandseinsatz.
Ja, aber dann musst du den Umweg über American Express machen.
Ja, aber ist egal, du bleibst in Euroland.
Ja, dann bist du wahrscheinlich mit Pfund günstiger.
Ja, okay, du hast halt American Express Einsatzgebühren. Nicht in der Währungsstelle, dann beißt dich die andere Ecke.
Aber ich finde schon, ihr solltet mal ein bisschen auf die Tube drücken, weil das ist schon ein Kaufgrund für so eine Apple Watch. Sonst macht die ja nicht so richtig viel Sinn.
Auch bitte nicht schon wieder die Diskussion. Die hatten wir auch neulich schon, wofür wir die Apple Watch benutzen.
Das ist ja auch keine Diskussion, das ist ja nur Aussage. Ich müsste ja nicht kommentieren.
Ja, also dafür möchte ich das auch gerne benutzen. Aber jetzt merke ich halt erstmal, was das eigentlich für eine soziale Veränderung wieder ist.
Da geht noch was.
Naja, jetzt musst du dich erstmal trauen. Jetzt musst du erstmal so in jedem Laden so, haben die kontaktloses Payment? Halte ich jetzt irgendjemand damit auf?
Eben nicht, du bist ja viel schneller als alle anderen.
Naja, also...
Außer wenn der Kassierer von dir verlangt, dass du irgendwas unterschreibst.
Nein, du kommst zum Beispiel irgendwo hin und du siehst überhaupt erstmal gar keine elektronische Bezahlmöglichkeit. Normalerweise, wenn ich in so einen Kaffee gehe und mir einen Milchkaffee hole, und es gibt genug Cafés, die hier immer noch cash-only sind, oder, keine Ahnung, hier Cocktailbars und so weiter, das sind ja alles totale Digitalgeld-Verächter. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die das aus privatsphäre Gründen oder... Natürlich ist das nur hier so.
Geh nach Schweden, da hast du das nicht. Da kannst du am Eisstand, der mit seinem Schirm auf der Straße steht, kannst du da mit deinen scheiß Kreditkarten bezahlen.
Aber das mein soziales Problem ist ja in Deutschland. Demnächst wahrscheinlich noch mehr, als mir lieb ist. Hier heißt es erstmal rausfinden, gibt es hier überhaupt kontaktloses Payment oder elektronisches Payment? Weil bisher war ich eigentlich auch... Ich bin ja durchaus ein Freund des Barzahlens. Wenn es nicht manchmal nur so unfassbar, unpraktisch wäre, wenn man gerade keine Zeit hat. Und ehrlich gesagt, will ich auch nur deshalb jetzt mit der Uhr zahlen, because I can und weil das halt, naja, potenziell...
Ich mache es ja immer noch. Ich bin jetzt über die Geht-das-Fragezeichen-Phase hinaus. Ich mache es immer noch gerade in Situationen, wenn es schnell gehen muss. Wenn du mit einer Kreditkarte zahlst, musst du immer noch mindestens eine PIN irgendwo einhaken, denn rappelt das Ding eh nochmal ein paar Sekunden lang. Oder schlimmstenfalls irgendwo unterschreiben. Und bei Bargeld, das ganze Fummel rein und raus, dann hast du was in der Hand, und dann hast du nicht das passende, oder keine Ahnung, so ein Scheiß, ja. Und das mit Uhr ist wirklich so klick, das geht so schnell, habe ich noch nie irgendwas bezahlt, egal wie sonst.
Na ja, mein Rewe soll es ja angeblich auch gehen. Ja, geht. Dann bin ich hier nebenan in diesem Rewe, und dann bin ich kontaktlos, und ich würde das gerne mal ausprobieren. Dann habe ich irgendwie mein Telefon geschwungen, gedrückt und gewädelt und gehalten.
Die müssen nicht aktivieren, die Terminalgie.
Nein, die aktivieren das immer, wenn normale EC-Karten auch aktiv sind.
Die hast du aber nicht in der Hand, deswegen hat die Kassiererin der Terminal nicht auf Kartenakzeptanz gestellt.
Es hat nicht funktioniert, Freund.
Ich bezahle bei Rewe damit. Vielleicht ist es nicht bei deinem?
Sag ihm ja den Laden, wo du warst, und schicke ihn dahin.
Ich rede nicht von einem technischen Problem, ich rede von einem sozialen Problem. Diese sozialen Probleme hatte ich bei meinen kurzen Testphasen bereits. Kein Terminal in sich. Danach fragen, hält alle anderen auf. Man kommt sich bekloppt vor. Oder man hat danach gefragt. Das war so ein bisschen wie bei Lurio. Lass doch mal das Kind nach vorn. Ins Essen gequatscht. Dann steht er so, ah, da möchte einer mit seinem Overwatch bezahlen.
Und dann steht er so drumherum und so, na, funktioniert's?
Nein, mein Name ist Fritlav, ich kaufe hier einen.
Und es war wirklich so Schweißtreibend.
Ich dachte so, nein, ich wollte nicht im Mittelpunkt stehen.
Ich wollte einfach nur bezahlen.
Machst dezent unterm Hoodie. Das ist immer noch die beste Methode. Diese Jedi-Methode. Dieses, ich muss hier nicht bezahlen.
Ich könnte mir so ein schwarzes Zaubertuch, so ein schillerndes, glänzendes schwarzes Tuch, was ich so über den Karten rüberwerfe.
In dem Chaos-Campoody. Du, ich hatte das doch erzählt mit dem Chaos-Campoody. Wo ich dann einfach die Uhr rumdrehe, in dem Hoodieärmel, dass man sie nicht sieht. Und dann halt über den Terminal rüber so, ich muss hier nicht bezahlen. Die Kassiererin fragt mich dann, so, äh, was war das jetzt? Ich sag, ja, Jedi-Meintrick. Ach, das geht jetzt auch, meint sie.
Auch. Jedi-Meintrick. Die sieht so aus, das wird auch lustig.
Das war übrigens, die war richtig trocken, die Frau.
Die kannte ich als Star Wars nicht. Sonst hätten sie dich wahrscheinlich festgenommen.
Wieso? Ihre Kasse hat dir gesagt, das ist alles okay. Aber mit den Zylindern ist es auch nicht schlecht, das sollte man auch mal machen. Die müssen noch den einen Unterschied, falls du den schon festgestellt hast. Wenn du ein Telefon benutzt, hinterlässt du in der Wallet so ein Receipt. Das heißt, da siehst du, wo du, also nicht wat, sondern wo du eingekauft hast, für wie viel Geld.
Nur im Telefon, nicht in der Watch oder was?
In der Watch nicht, nee.
Das ist ja aber auch zum Telefon rüber schicken, oder?
Das sollte doch dann synchronisiert werden, oder?
Wenn du dann drauf tippst auf das Ding, siehst du hier unten da, das sind all die Transaktionen.
Auch wenn die auf die Karte tippen.
Gibt es eigentlich, bei EC-Karten sagen die immer so 5 Euro Mindestgebühr, das gibt es aber da dann auch, weil für die ist ja das Gleiche, ne?
Ah nee, hab ich hier auch von meiner Watch, das ist egal. Oder?
Nee, nicht auf der Watch, nicht auf der Uhr. Du findest das nicht auf der Uhr. Das findest du nur auf dem Telefon.
Jungs, die Mindestsumme, die man bezahlt, das ist das Gleiche, ne?
Die Kasse ist nicht eine Kreditkarte.
Okay, verstehe.
Müssen dann aber auch mal runtersetzen, irgendwann.
Ist ja schon bei zwei Euro oder so, bei den meisten Läden. Oder Tankstellen, glaub ich.
Ich glaub, Tobias will sich ausklinken, oder?
Also von wollen kann keine Rede sein, aber... Von müssen.
Ja, macht jetzt einen auf Früharbeiter.
Flugzeug.
Nee.
Kindergarten.
U-Bahn.
U-Bahn?
Um 6?
Ja, wenn wir mal U-Bahn zum Flughafen hätten in Berlin.
Wir haben nicht mal Flughafen.
Ja.
Das war's denn.
Kann ich ja verstehen. Ja, schön war's.
Ja, fand ich auch.
Tobias, vielen Dank fürs Kommen.
Für die Einladung.
Wir machen dann aber noch ein bisschen weiter. Ohne mich?
Achso, du wirst auch gehen. Ja, wenn ich jetzt einfach gehe, dann lacht der Huckel mich aus. Du kannst ja nochmal, wir können auch eine kurze Sendung machen.
Du kannst ja mal von deinem Blitzschutz reden, weil jetzt hatten wir ja gerade hier so Wetter-Dramen in Berlin heute. Nicht nur hier, aber jetzt hier auch mal.
Es kam halt bei mir nur in den letzten zwei Wochen so ein bisschen zusammen, dass ich mehrfach Router neu installieren musste, weil die entweder einfach nur, der simple ging halt einfach nicht mehr oder tat halt nicht mehr alles, was er sollte, bis hin zu du schüttelst den Router und hörst dann die Echoes drin klappern. Und das ultimative Teil war ein Router, den es richtig von der Wand abgefetzt hat.
Da waren auch irgendwo installiert, wo kein Blitzerpleiter war?
Ja, da waren witzigerweise an unterschiedlichsten Orten. Also der erste Fall war der, ich war jetzt in Frankreich, mal wieder in den Bergen, hab die Freundin schon mal privat hier so erzählt, eine GPRS-Erfahrung, mal nach vielen Jahren, mal wieder schlichtet GPRS, das ist schon hart. Ist aber interessant, was noch alles geht mit GPS. Aber egal, jedenfalls gab es dort, die Franzosen sind ja nicht so wie in Deutschland, da gibt es schon seit Jahren auch DSL mitten auf dem Land, halt nächste Dorf mit fünf Nasen, irgendwie eine Stunde weg und so zu laufen, also richtig auf dem Land. Die haben da immerhin, sage und schreibe, so 7 Megabit DSL, was bei denen da den Berg runtergekullert kommt, auf so einer langen Leitung. Und die Leute, die die Etablissements dort betreiben, sind natürlich schlau, wenn die Schlechtwetter ankommen sehen, ziehen sie alle draus. Wie das halt so ein normaler Verbraucher macht, wie ihm das seine Eltern nochmal beigebracht haben, und zwar so rausziehen, nicht abschalten, sondern rausziehen. Nun ist es aber so, das Internet ist ja inzwischen auch eine Droge für viele. Es gibt natürlich diese Junkies, die wenn sie nicht mindestens alle drei Stunden mal ihre E-Mails checken können, dann drehen die ja voll am Rad. Das heißt, die Besitzer des Etablissements haben das Ding brav aus der Wand gezogen, als es irgendwo donnerte. Und irgendwo ein Junkie, der auch auf demselben Gelände war, dachte sich, oh jetzt kann ich aber gar kein E-Mail lesen. Was ist denn das? Ach, den Wuter hat ja gar keinen, der steckt ja gar nicht in der Wand, also stecke ich ihn mal wieder rein. Tate das auch und dann kam es natürlich, wie es kommen musste, der Blitz schlug irgendwo in der Nähe ein. Das ist übrigens auch so ein Mythos, dass die Leute mal denken, bei mir schlägt der Blitz nicht ein, muss er gar nicht. Weil wenn der Blitz bei dir wirklich einschlägt, dann hast du ganz andere Sorgen. Das Problem bei der Elektronik ist, gerade bei langen Leitungen der Blitz schlägt halt irgendwo in der Nähe ein, erzeugt ein schönes Magnetfeld. Dieses Magnetfeld induziert auf den Leitern, das heißt auf allen Leitern, nicht nur auf der Stromleitung, sondern auch auf der Telefonleitung oder auch auf einem langen Ethernet-Kabel. Einfach eine schöne Überspannung. Es sind jetzt nicht ein paar Tausend oder ein paar Millionen Volt, sondern es sind genug, um mal so eine kleine DSL-Mode aus den Angeln zu heben oder ein Ethernet-Trinziber, der in dem Gerät eingebaut ist, wenn es auf einem Ethernet-Kabel passiert. Deswegen helfen dort auch relativ einfach Überspannungsschutz-Dinger, die jetzt nicht gleich explodieren, weil wie gesagt, der Blitz schlägt da nicht direkt in das Kabel ein, sondern erzeugt halt nur durch sein Magnetfeld eine Überspannung auf dem Kabel. Naja, also wie gesagt, dieses Ding ist dann schön auseinandergefallen. Das war der Router, wo man die Elkos dann klappern hören konnte. Da hast du den geschüttelt und da hast du durch die Lüftungslöcher reingeguckt. Da kullerten so runde Tonnen drin rum und dem Ding, den Hals also richtig gerissen. Ähm, warum? Sehr lustig, weil ähm, äh, wir haben dann eine von diesen Internet-Junkies, die da mit waren auf dem Camp, die auch mit Auto da waren, haben dann losgeschickt in die nächste Stadt, haben gesagt, du sprichst ordentlich Französisch, jetzt nimmst du mal bitte diesen Router und gehst mal in den nächsten Orange-Shop, also Franz Telekom, und sagst, wer dir da kaputt neuen haben will und so. Hat sie auch gemacht, sehr resolute Frau ist dann hingegangen, und die haben dann so tipptippt, ja, hm, la, haben wir schon gehört, hat ja schon jemand angerufen, ja, wir schicken ihnen Dienstag einen neuen, das war so an einem Sonneabend. Und sie so, nein, das geht gar nicht, ich brauche Internet jetzt, und Dienstag, ihr habt ja wohl einen Schaden, und hat voll den Affentanz da gemacht, und die haben so, ja, okay, gut, hier hast du so einen Router, nimm mit. Und übrigens ganz, ganz fieset gerät, diese Kiste, Französisch Modell von Zageme, fieseste Benutzer, die ich je gesehen habe in meinem Leben, und egal, kann man anders mal drüber rennen. Haben wir aber, wie gesagt, wieder repariert. Aber es kam wieder auch so, das Ding reingesteckt, ein paar Tage später, wie es donnert, wir ziehen es raus, irgendein Internet-Junkie eine Stunde später steckt es wieder rein. Den haben wir zum Glück rechtzeitig erwischt und wieder rausgezogen, aber wie gesagt, wenn man die Dinger rauszieht, muss man sie auch draußen lassen, wollte ich nur sagen. Man muss die Internet-Junkies fernhalten mit einer Kette oder mit einem Gitter oder so, dass das Ding nicht einfach wieder reinstecken.
Einfach mehr Ersatzgeräte auf Lager haben.
Story 2 auf meinem Landsitz in dem Dorf schlug mal in der Tat wirklich ein Blitz ein. Und zwar in einen Wäsche-Ständer bei einem der Leute, die dort wohnen. Das hat schon mal interessante Spuren hinterlassen auf den Wäscheleinen, die nämlich teilweise auch so aus Draht waren oder so. Die sahen sehr lustig aus.
Ja, Wäscheleine haben Draht in den Drehungen und Plastik außenrum.
Genau. Und die sahen sehr lustig aus. Hat leider kein Foto gemacht, ich hab nicht dran gedacht. Jedenfalls war das sehr lustig, weil im Umkreis von diesem Gebäude befinden sich diverse Sachen. Bei dem Typen selber ist der Router von der Wand geflogen. Der hat diverse Sachen aus der Wand geschossen. Im näheren Umfeld hat es auch alles an Elektronik weggebürstet, was da war bei allen Nachbarn. Die üblichen Satellit-Receiver, Router, sowieso alles.
Ich hab letztens gelesen, warum da so schlimme Sachen passieren. Weil man denkt, warum fällt der Router runter. Aber es ist so, dass die Leitungen in den Wänden verdampfen. Dadurch gibt es kleine Mini-Explosionen. Deswegen fallen da Sachen runter.
Oder in der Kiste selber. Es hat zum Glück nix gebrannt. Jedenfalls sah es lustig aus. Im weiteren Umfeld des Dorfes, die jetzt keinen Überspannungsschutz hatten, mussten ihre ganzen Router austauschen.
Überspannungsschutz soll auch nur helfen, wenn bei den Nachbarn was ist, damit man nicht so viel abbekommt. Wenn nicht der Blitz erwischt, dann nützt das alles nichts mehr.
Bei dir ist es einfach, genau. Ich habe zum Beispiel Überspannungsschutz drin, mein Zeug lief weiter. Die Telekom hat offenbar keinen Überspannungsschutz drin, weil es gibt eine kleine GSM-Basestation in dem Ort, auch so im 30-Meter-Umfeld. Oder gab. Genau. Hängt dort im Feuerwehrschuppen. Was passierte? Zwei Tage später kam jemand von der Telekom, holte sich den Schlüssel für den Feuerwehrschuppen, machte ihn auf, schraute rein, zog mit den Schultern, sagte, da kann man nichts machen, und verpisste sich wieder. Und in diesem Zustand ist es heute noch. Der Blitz schlug da vor 17 oder 18 Tagen ein. Ich hab jetzt mal ein bisschen Terror gemacht bei der Telekom, und die fragten, so, wollte das Ding nicht doch mal reparieren? Wieso, da ist doch nichts. Doch, die ganze Basisstation ist da weg. Da war auch jemand da von euch, aber der hat gesagt, da kann man nichts machen, und verpisste sich wieder. Die dann so, oh, oh, oh. Da hab ich sie kurz daran erinnert, warum diese Basisstation da ist, für den Fall, dass ihr das nicht wisst. Dafür durfte die die ganzen Telefonzellen abbauen, die Notrufgeschichte, die kam vorhin drauf, kurz zu sprechen, gab nämlich ganz früher auf eine echte Telefonzelle. Das mag die Telekom nicht, weil das kostet sie viel mehr Geld, als das es ihr bringt. Deswegen haben sie die irgendwann mal runtergedampft auf so ein Notruftelefon. Weißt du, diese Dinger, wo so eine Telefonzelle ohne Zelle...
So eine Säule.
So eine Säule, wo du halt so Notrufe mitmachen kannst.
Ohne Stick.
Das war ihnen aber auch irgendwie zu teuer, und außerdem ist das denn nicht, keine Ahnung, da gibt es keine VoIP-Version von oder so was. Sie wollen ja eh das ganze ISDM-Telefonnetz einrollen, und damit sie das dürfen, hat man dann regulierungstechnisch auch gesagt, na gut, dann wollen wir halt wenigstens Mobilfunkversorgung dort haben, dass die Leute Notrufe über das Mobiltelefon wählen können. Deswegen mussten sie eine kleine GSM-BTS dahin bauen. Ist wirklich nur so ein Edge-Ding. Das ist ein ganz kleines Kästchen nur, hängt an einem DSL-Anschluss. Ja, sozusagen, und hat oben eine Antenne drauf und macht eben auch nur GSM und Edge. Ja, aber macht kein 3G, keine LTE oder sonst irgendwas.
Zwei Sachen dazu. Das erste ist, es muss ein sehr kleiner Blitz gewesen sein. Weil das ist erstmal, es klingt unlogisch, aber je mehr Energie der Blitz hat, desto länger ist der Blitzweg. Und desto größer, also musst du dir vorstellen, so ein Radius, so eine Kugel mit so einem Radius. Und wenn du die so über die Landschaft rollst, dann schlägt der Blitz da ein, wo es am höchsten ist. Wenn es aber bei jemandem im Garten die Wäsche-Spinde war, dann ist der eigentliche Blitzradius sehr kurz. Das heißt, der Blitz hatte auch nicht viel Energie.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Augenzeugen. Es gibt Augenzeugen, die meinten, das Ding wäre in die Antenne von der GSM-BTS reingegangen und hätte sich dann fortgepflanzt, dann nochmal quergeschossen bis zu dem Typen in den Garten rein. Es gibt auch andere Augenzeugen, die haben das Ding nur im Dorf niedergehend sehen, aber nicht genau, wo es eingeschlagen ist. Also es gibt da keine exakten Erkenntnisse dazu. Ich habe bloß den Wäscheständer und die Wäscheleine gesehen, und das sah lustig aus.
Mein Vater ist ja gelernter Fernsehtechniker meister, und der ist irgendwann mal zu einem Kunden gerufen worden, wo tatsächlich der Blitz so eingeschlagen hat, dass auf der Antennensteckdose gegenüberliegenden Wand fast die gesamte Wand schwarz war. Also was genau passiert, ist es nicht klar, aber es hat auf jeden Fall ganz ordentlich gerumst.
Also es ist immer noch ein nettes, leider sehr gefährliches Spielzeug, aber so ein Blitz ist schon...
Da muss ordentlich Feuer aus der Wand gekommen sein, als das Ding da rein ist.
Tim, bevor ich jetzt endgültig gehe, was mir gerade noch einfällt, wo du vorhin gefragt hast, was ich eigentlich so toll finde und schlecht finde am MacBook oder Betriebssystem oder so, was mir gerade noch aufgefallen ist, was ich also wirklich eigentlich total inakzeptabel finde, ist... dass ich hier so ein Letzchen brauche, was ich irgendwie zwischen...
Hatte ich auch bei meinem Thinkpad früher....
was ich zwischen Tastatur und Display lege, weil ansonsten, weil das Ding so konstruiert ist, dass einfach der Abstand zwischen Display und Tastatur nicht vorhanden ist und sich sonst einfach die Tastatur mit der Zeit in das Display rein...
Nicht die Tastatur, sondern dein Fingerfett, wenn du mal mit deinen dreckigen Fingern auf der Tastatur rumhobeln musst.
Ich behaupte, dass du deinen Laptop zu dicht einpackst und da zu viel Druck von außen kommt.
Ja, das hat Apple auch gesagt, aber ich habe...
Bei meinem ist das nicht so. Meiner kommt ganz locker in meinen Rucksack und wird mit nichts zusammengedrückt.
Du hast ja auch ein deutlich dickeres Modell, wo einfach mehr Abstand ist.
Ja, aber wir haben die gleiche Displaykante, wie ich das hier so fühle. Die Tastatur ist bei dir jetzt auch nicht anders als bei mir. Also der Rest mag bei dir dünner sein, aber...
Ich hatte diese Läppchen schon bei meinem letzten Thinkpad drin, lange vor meinem ersten Apple-Ding. Weil ich selber Probleme hatte, wenn ich das Ding im Rucksack habe und den Rucksack halt aufpresse oder in der U-Bahn gedrängelt werde, also dann drückst du halt das Display zwangsläufig auf die Tastatur.
Ich hab ja diese Tasche hier, und da wird halt einfach kein Dollar Druck ausgeübt. Ich hab dann mal, als mir das bei einem Apple-Händler jemand erzählen wollte, hab ich dann mal so einen Test gemacht, da hab ich so ein Post-It genommen und hab einfach nur die Klebefläche abgeschaltet, dass ich nur die Klebefläche hatte. Und hab das einfach umgekehrt mit Klebefläche nach oben auf die Tastatur gelegt und hab den zugeklappt und hab ihn wieder aufgeklappt und der Post-It klebt am Display.
Gut, da ist ja noch ein Post-It dazwischen. Das wäre ja normalerweise...
Ein netter Versuch, ja.
Also das ist jetzt nicht besonders wissenschaftlich, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Jedenfalls finde ich das für ein 3000-Euro-Gerät einfach nicht.
Nee, er ist auch unakzeptabel und ich hab das Gefühl, das hängt von dem versteckten Modell an.
Nee, mit dicker hätte ich überhaupt gar kein Problem. Ich hatte ja vorher Zinkpads.
Du nicht, aber die ganzen Hipster, die den Scheiß kaufen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, ja.
Aber mein R ist ja nun auch recht schmal, da hab ich das Problem nicht. Ich kenne das aber noch von den alten, damals, weißte noch, so Pismo, diese Lombard-Generation und so. Da war das richtig krass. Und irgendwie ist das nicht mehr so...
Also ich hatte so ein Pismo und das Pismo, das hatte ja keine Glasscheibe. Vorm Display.
Sondern? Ach so, nur...
Das Display hatte ja diese Plastik. Naja, dieses raue Plastik.
Ich habe das auch nur hier bei meinem R.
Bei denen ist ja so eine Art Glasscheibe davor. Und da haben sich, bei dem Pismo, haben sich die Tasten so weit in diese Scheibe eingearbeitet, dass das halt dann auch nicht mehr wegging, diese Abdrücke waren da.
Geht nicht mehr weg. Das ist aber dein Fingerfett, was sehr aggressiv ist, wenn du auf dem Plastik-Test...
Nein, nein, nein, das war wirklich die Tastatur.
Du hast doch einen Retina-Teil, das ist doch Glas.
Also pass auf, es war wirklich die Tastatur. Mein Fingerfett, das kannst du hier oben sehen.
Nein, nein, nicht das Fingerfett auf dem Display. Denn wenn du auf der Tastatur tippst, hinterlässt du dort Fingerfett. Ich weiß, was du meinst. Wenn du die Tastatur dagegen drückst, dann überträgt sich dieses chemisch-aggressive Fingerfett auf die Glotze.
Es waren aber nur die Ecken von den Tasten.
Ja, da ist aber auch Fingerfett.
Du tippst einfach zu viel.
Einfach mal Hände waschen.
Das ist nicht akzeptabel.
Du tippst jetzt mal die nächste Zeit nur mit Handschuhen, so mit Latex-Handschuhen oder so, so OP-Handschuhe. Und dann guckst du. Dann ist das Einzige, was du auf deinem Display noch findest, danach diese Teilkommen oder so.
Das ist eine Win-Situation. Ich meine, nun stell dir einfach mal vor, du gehst zum Kunden. Und dann holst du dann irgendwann in so einem entscheidenden Moment, kurz nachdem du noch mal so gegrübelt hast, dein Laptop raus, und ziehst aber, bevor du irgendeine Taste drückst, das mal weiße Handschuhe an. Ja, so Finger noch vorne noch so ein bisschen strecken.
Ein bisschen knacken lassen?
Nee, knacken ist viel zu aufdringlich. Nee, einfach nur so ein bisschen ausstrecken, kurz noch so ein bisschen Gleichgewicht suchen und dann mit so einem, so wie man an Dante irgendwie ein Klavierkonzert beginnen würde, so setzt du dann irgendwie die Finger auf. Tipps dann so ein bisschen ganz leise, es klackert ja auch gar nicht mehr, und dann ist gut.
Ich habe noch einen, und zwar Usability. Ich sitze ja auch gern draußen, wenn das Wetter es erlaubt und arbeite. Wenn die Sonne scheint, das alte Problem, ich kann mit dem Ding nicht, weil ich nichts auf dem Display sehen würde, ich werde einfach blind, weil die Sonne einfach wie Blöde von diesem Aluminium reflektiert. Auf den Dingern steht drauf, designt in Kalifornien, aber benutzt offensichtlich nur Indoor.
Das Motto des Bundesstaats Kalifornien lautet The Sunshine State.
Und was ich jetzt getan habe, ist, ich habe mir aus einem Stück Pappe eine Maske geschnitten, die ich immer da drüber lege, die halt nur das Touchpad und die Kastatur freilässt.
Warum hast du dir denn nicht in deinem nächsten Hackspace einfach das scheiß Gehäuse schwarz eloxieren lassen? Wenn es überhaupt geht.
Demnächst gibt es das ja in Space Grey. Also wird ja gemunkelt. Ja, das nächste MacBook Pro wird unter Garantie auch in Gold.
Wahrscheinlich nur mit dem D-Render.
Nee, nee, wenn das schon alles. Na so wie das halt.
Also das könnt ihr schon mal besser umbringen. Ansonsten gibt es ja noch so, es gibt ja tatsächlich so Produkte, so komplette Hauben, wo du sozusagen dein Bild schon mal dich in so einem schwarzen Tunnel irgendwie...
Deswegen sitzt es ja draußen in der Sonne.
Das ist aber nicht, wenn du draußen sitzen willst, das ist, wenn du draußen sitzen musst, gegen deinen Willen.
Ja, ich verstehe das.
Aber ich muss sagen... Das dunkle Keller verließ für den Hacker. Draußen in der Sonne sitzen.
Naja, wir wissen ja alle. Wie sagt der Hacker zur Sonne? Der böse Tagesstern. Tobias, vielen Dank.
Danke auch.
Hey du.
Fürs Kommen und Beitragen. Und das schallt jetzt auch gerade aus dem unhörbaren Hörerinnenraum zurück.
Das bin ich mir sicher.
Genau.
Dann ja, euch noch viel Spaß.
Und wir sagen erstmal Tschüss. Tobias, du bist jetzt raus und wir machen jetzt hier einen Abgang.
Wir machen auch einen Abgang, nein.
Ich habe jetzt keinen Bock mehr, mit der Doka zu renten. Du darfst noch etwas über die iOS 10 Device Support erzählen.
Und zwar, diese iOS Support Matrix, die ich immer so viel gelobt habe, die wird ganz offensichtlich nicht mehr weiter gepflegt. Die ist immer noch bei 9.0 Beta 2. Warte mal, die iOS Support Matrix. So ein Dokument, wo drin steht, welches Device was kann. Vor allen Dingen iOS Version. Link, Chat. Egal. Wie gesagt, die wird nicht mehr gepflegt. Ist halt auch hoffnungslos outdated inzwischen, weil sie halt kein iOS 10 mehr beinhaltet. Und ich wollte jetzt einfach mal wissen, welche Devices fliegen denn jetzt tatsächlich raus? Habe also die Downloads von Apple verglichen mit dem, was es so an Devices in dieser Matrix gibt und seitdem neu vorgestellt wurde. Und es fliegen also, wenn ich das richtig sehe, fünf Devices raus. Und das Interessante daran ist, dass es nicht am Speicher liegt, am RAM, weil zumindest das The New iPad 3. Generation hat immer noch einen Gig Speicher, alle anderen nur ein halbes Gig. Sondern es fliegen alle Devices raus, die die ARM V7-Prozessorarchitektur haben. Und alle, die die ARM V7s-Prozessorarchitektur haben, sind noch dabei.
Ist ja das gleiche wie bei den Desktop-Laptops, dass da halt dieses SSE 4.1 jetzt irgendwie benutzt wird.
Was ist nochmal der Unterschied zwischen den beiden?
Genau, und jetzt habe ich versucht herauszufinden, was der Unterschied zwischen den beiden Prozessorarchitekturen ist, und es ist mir nicht gelungen. Also es scheint ein paar Änderungen in der Floating-Point-Arithmetik zu geben, weil es da irgendwelche neuen Befehle gibt, die Sachen schneller machen können. Aber so eine richtig gute Erklärung gibt es irgendwie nicht. Es gibt bei Wikipedia nicht mal eine Erklärung, was die Arm-V7-S-Architektur eigentlich ist.
In welcher Wikipedia? In der deutschen oder in der englischen?
In der englischen. In der deutschen vielleicht schon.
Weil SSD noch supported ist, oder was? Vielleicht hat der Apfel da noch ein anderes Feature drin, was sie auf dem Core mit drauf gemacht haben zu dem Arm-Design.
S könnte natürlich für Secure Enclave stehen.
Zum Beispiel.
Das hieße dann halt, dass sie alle Geräte, die diese Secure Enclave nicht mehr haben, jetzt dann wirklich rausschmeißen.
Das heißt also 4S und 5 auch noch.
iPad 2 hat es nicht, iPad 4S hat es nicht, iPad 3. Generation hat es nicht, iPad Touch 5. Generation und das iPad Mini, das allererste.
Aber iPhone 5 hat es noch, oder was?
iPhone 5 hat es, 4. Generation, iPad 5C.
Und iPad Mini Retina, das erste?
So, und das erste iPad Mini Retina hat ja schon einen 64-Bit, also einen A7, also dieser Apple A5 AX-Chip, das ist der, der rausfliegt. Und alles ab A6 A6X ist noch drin. Und alles ab A7 hat schon 64-Bit.
Also also 32-Bit fliegt bei dem noch nicht raus.
32-Bit fliegt noch nicht raus.
Zumindest nicht deswegen.
Obwohl du immer wieder Warnungen kriegst bei Applikationen, die nicht 64-Bit enthalten. So nach der Art, diese Applikation ist nur 32-Bit und macht das ganze System langsam. Was ich auch immer sehr interessant finde. Also, keine Ahnung, wenn irgendjemand mal rausfindet, was es mit dieser armen V7S-Architektur auf sich hat, das fände ich mal ganz spannend.
Chatfragen. Chat weiß ja alles, ne?
Chat weiß alles, ja.
iossupportmatrix.com, das ist das, wovon du redest.
Genau, und die ist, wie gesagt, iOS 9 steht da mit 9.0 Beta 2, das ist natürlich schon eine Weile her.
Ist das so eine Matrix auch für macOS jetzt eigentlich?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Nee.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht Apple.
Sieht aber so aus.
Die macht das halt, hat das eine Weile lang gemacht und macht es halt jetzt nicht mehr.
Schade eigentlich, für macOS würde ich das auch gerne mal sehen.
Schon sehr Apple-Style, wundert mich ja, dass ihn da nicht der Apple, irgendwelche gelangweilten Apple-Loyer an den Hals fallen für. Oh, das ganze Ding auch oben mit der Fahne in dem Kuller, die ganze Optik, mit diesen, ja, die Fonts und so. Das Ding hat das auch von Apple. Diese Aufteilung, die Fonts und so, das alles dafür. Aber egal.
Auf Deutsch. iOS-Unterstützung-Matrix, da.
Die Leute immer noch glauben, dass das, was aus Google Translate rausfällt, wirklich deutsch sein soll.
Das machen sie letztes Jahr immer öfter mit Untertiteln von Movies. Die nehmen eigentlich nur Untertitel. Die jagen die durch Google Translate und dann denkst du, das sind jetzt deutsche Untertitel.
Wenn man es jetzt nicht für sowas benutzt, ist Google Translate immer wieder noch richtig gut. Man kann jetzt übrigens auch Offline-Translations runterladen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gesehen habt. Es gibt ja von Google Translate auch eine App. Also, kannst du nicht mehr über die Webseite benutzen, dann gibt es auch eine App für iOS. Das ist die, die haben wir schon mal besprochen, wo du mit Sachen so Schilder mit abfotografierst oder live in dem Videobild, in dieser Augmented Reality, die Texte ersetzt. Was recht nützlich ist, gerade wenn man so im komisch sprechenden Ausland unterwegs ist. Und du kannst jetzt Offline Translations drunter laden für, keine Ahnung, 30 oder 50 Sprachen oder so. Das heißt, du kannst es dann auch wirklich mitnehmen nach Japan und ohne Roaming und la la la dein Google Translate da benutzen, was ich auch ganz nett finde.
Nicht verkehrt, wenn ich mal wieder in Japan bin.
Egal, das kannst du auch woanders probieren. Aber wir haben hier in Europa immer weniger dieses Roaming-Problem mit den Daten. Das heißt, da kannst du auch die Online-Version benutzen. Aber wenn du halt eben außerhalb der EU dich rumtreibst, ist Roaming halt teuer.
Ja, die meisten europäische Sprachen sind jetzt auch nicht so schwer, dass man nicht ungefähr mitkriegt, worum es geht.
Sagt der Mann, der jetzt vielleicht demnächst mal nach Finnland fährt und dann die selber Aussage versucht zu treffen? Kannst du auch Ungarn ausprobieren?
Ich fand Bulgarien jetzt auch relativ anspruchsvoll. Schon wieder eine Fliege.
Ist ja fast wie beim Finale hier.
Ich war am Samstag im Room 77 wieder bei der Bitcoin Halving-Party.
Was? Halving?
Ja, der Bitcoin-Output pro Block wurde doch halbiert. Das passiert alle 210.000 Blöcke. Oder auch ungefähr alle vier Jahre. Und das passierte exakt 18.42 Uhr. Und dann haben wir wieder dick gefeiert. Und alle dachten, der Kurs steigt dann, oder die Miner steigen aus, und die Hechrate sinkt und so. Aber wie ich schon vorausgesagt habe, ist genau gar nichts passiert. Und alles geht genau ganz normal weiter. Und es ist sozusagen gut, dass nichts passiert ist. Eigentlich, finde ich. Nein, niemand meint mir, außer ein paar Chinesen. Und vielleicht noch ein paar Verrückte, die Strom geklaut haben, die nicht bezahlen müssen.
Du hast jetzt noch ein paar Bitcoins hier in Wurmlung an, mit denen du jetzt noch...
Ich habe so ein paar auf meinem Telefon, damit ich mir noch ein paar Burger kaufen kann.
Aber ansonsten ist der Zug abgefahren.
Für Bitcoin, ja.
Also fürs Mining.
Ja, nee, Mining kannst du vergessen.
Zahlungsmittel für Erpressertrojaner und so.
Da ist es super. Und auch wenn man sich im Ausland VPN-Dienste bezahlen möchte, ist es super. Oder wenn man in Russland seltene Musik kauft.
Russland seltene Musik? Was haben wir jetzt darunter mir vorzustellen?
Ich habe da vor ein paar Tagen einen Artikel vorbeifliegen sehen, wo jemand mit so einem Proxy sich angeguckt hat, was der Bitcoin-Trojaner tatsächlich zu seinem Server zurückmeldet. Und dann in dem entsprechenden Request hat er dann mal die Zahl geändert.
Dass man nicht mehr so viel bezahlen muss, oder wie?
Genau, und es ist aber trotzdem durchgegangen. Und dann hat er den Dollar bezahlt und der Trojaner hat trotzdem entschlüsselt.
Ja, habe ich auch gelesen in der Nachricht.
Ach so, dass man überhaupt was bezahlt, aber er checkt den Betrag nicht, oder was?
Genau, irgendwie sowas.
Oh, das ist ja auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, aber das hat er jetzt wahrscheinlich gefixt.
Wer weiß?
Kann er aber vielleicht auch nicht fixen, wer weiß. Vielleicht ist das ja irgendwo so automatisiert und er ist nicht mehr da, wo das Ding läuft, weil er will ja nicht erwischt werden. Das einzige, was er hat, ist, wenn er schlau ist, die Bitcoin-Wallet-Adresse, die dann ihm gehört.
Ich bin übrigens noch einem Apple-Dienst auf den Leim gegangen. Also was heißt auf den Leim gegangen? Also ich habe ihn jetzt nach mehreren Jahren seiner Existenz begonnen zu benutzen, inklusive Zahlen. Jetzt bin ich gespannt, was passiert.
Für Musik? Nee, iCloud.
iTunes Match.
Ach so.
Wenn du das abschalten willst, dann fängst du an, das zu benutzen.
Das habe ich nichts darüber gelesen.
Diese ganze Content-Kauferei ist alles doch viel zu mühsam. Die wollen auch jetzt nur noch vermieten. Du solltest jetzt alles streamen. Du solltest auch möglichst gar keinen Content auf deinem Gerät mehr haben. Deswegen brauchst du auch nicht mehr als 16 GB.
Besitzt das noch so letztes Jahr 1000?
Genau. Du solltest jetzt alles streamen.
Was übrigens total nervig ist, weil es gibt bei iTunes keine Ärzte. Und das heißt, dass du bei Apple Music auch keine Ärzte bekommst. Wenn du aber in deiner Library-Ärzte drin hast und willst sie dann auf dem Phone hören, dann geht das nicht, weil er diese natürlich nicht bei Apple Music findet.
Du kannst sie da hochladen und dann werden die von dort wieder runtergeladen. Oder geht das dann nicht?
Nee, das geht nicht.
Ich dachte, die laden dann... Zumindest habe ich es nicht hingekriegt.
Es ist irgendwie...
Du solltest doch nicht einfach irgendeine Scheißmusik hören. Du solltest das hören, was die gute Firma Apple dir zur Verfügung stellt.
Das ist gut genug für dich.
Für mich war das einfach eine ganz pragmatische Entscheidung. Ich habe einfach das Problem... Letztes Jahr hatte ich das erste Mal so einen Urge von, ich muss Kisten aus meiner Wohnung rauskriegen, und jetzt habe ich gerade den zweiten.
Das kommt mit dem Alter, Kenneth.
Das kommt mit Umzügen.
Und dem Alter?
Na, Umzüge kommen ja mit dem Alter.
Ich dachte, die werden lediger mit dem Alter.
Naja, aber umso älter du wirst, umso mehr Umzüge wirst du irgendwann mal gemacht haben. Man, auf jeden Fall will man die Scheiße loswerden. Und wenn man so komplette Umzugskisten voll nur mit CDs findet, fragt man sich halt schon, genau was.
Die habe ich schon eine Weile hinter mir gelassen, aber ich bin auch mühelter als du.
Bist du älter als ich?
Ein bisschen.
Sicher?
Und dann sind die CDs alle weggeschmissen? Dann können wir ja nochmal durchdigitalisieren. Du hast das jetzt mit Watch erledigt.
Ich hatte schon mal die ersten zwei Kisten durchdigitalisiert und da hatte ich das Gefühl, hatte ich nicht mehr Musik. So wenig war das nur, heutzutage kommt einem das irgendwie so... In Erinnerung war das so viel. Und dann dachte ich mir so, vielleicht mit Grazios... Jetzt habe ich noch eine Kiste gefunden und da bin ich noch dabei, das hinterher zu rippen. Und dann habe ich aber immer wieder dieses Problem, dass ich die Scheiße, die ich jetzt gerade mal hören will, auch wirklich da habe. Und ich brauchte einfach mal eine ordentliche Syncing-Methode. Und alles andere mit Dropbox, mit BitTorrent. Es ist alles irgendwie elend. Und jetzt habe ich halt klein beigegeben und jetzt habe ich mir irgendwie ein Match angeschaltet.
Das ist bei Apple nicht, dass du neue Musik kriegst, sondern du zahlst jetzt monatlich dafür, dass du deine Musik, die du schon bezahlt hast, hören darfst. Auf allen Geräten dafür, aber... Genau. Wie viel?
25 Dollar im Euro im Jahr. Ja, also im Vergleich zu den anderen... Ich habe jetzt mal ein paar Monate dieses Netflix ausprobiert. Das ist so pointless, das habe ich jetzt wieder abbestellt. Und die rufen ja irgendwie ganz andere Summen auf.
Also das ist ja auch kein Vergleich. Netflix ist doch gar nicht Musik.
Nein, aber halt so Medien-Zugriff-Gedöns. Und dann weiß ich nicht, am Ende habe ich das Gefühl, dass das ganze Gestrima auch so Apple Music ist für mich irgendwie gar nichts.
Das nervt mich total ab, dass das nicht los wird.
Ich will einfach wissen, was ich suche und fertig. Und das habe ich da drin. Und was ich da nicht drin habe, das tue ich da rein. Aber ich will nicht unbedingt immer alles auf allen Rechnern jederzeit draufliegen haben, wo es irgendwie tonnenschwer rumliegt. Und dann im Zweifelsfall dann doch wieder nicht da ist, wenn man es braucht.
Ist jemand von euch eine iOS 10 Beta?
Ja, ich habe die drauf.
Darf ich den mal kurz sehen? Wir werden mal gucken, ob sie endlich wieder einen funktionierenden Music Player haben.
Also nichts geändert, oder?
Gute Frage, den habe ich mir noch gar nicht angeguckt.
Der wird von Mal zum Mal schlechter, in Abgründe steigt.
Timme, das Apple Match, ist das dann lossless? Oder kommen die dann so mit 256 oder wie kommen die zurück?
256.
Verstehe. Und du musst die aber alle einmal original durchrippen, sonst wird es ja von Match nicht erkannt, richtig?
Nein, wenn ich es einmal, nein, wenn ich es...
Deswegen bist du auch die ganze Zeit am CDs einschieben, ja? Nein, nein, alles...
Nein, es geht erstmal um meine Musik.
Ja, ja, schon klar. Aber das musst du ja erstmal rippen.
Digitale Musik halt natürlich. Ich kann ja meine Schallplatten nicht irgendwie automatisch ausfüllen.
Das ist schon klar, aber du musst jetzt alle deine CDs erstmal durchrippen, dann lernt iTunes Match dich kennen und dadurch kannst du sie dann von überall runterladen, weil sie das dann durch ihre eigenen Kopien ersetzen, wenn sie das auch da haben schon, so läuft das ja.
Ja, wenn, aber wenn nicht, dann ist das halt...
Es wird nicht hochgeladen, wenn sie das schon kennen, so läuft das, ne?
Beziehungsweise, wenn sie meinen, es zu kennen, dann ersetzen sie durch die Kopie, die sie schon haben, ja. Und das läuft halt oft auch mal schief. Jetzt bin ich aber nicht jemand, der schon seit 30 Jahren irgendwie so ein Digitalarchiv plant und mit tausend Texts versehen und so weiter. Also mein Verlust ist sozusagen, ich kann da keinen Verlust erleiden, das kann alles nur besser werden. Weil ich vorher halt einfach keine Lösung hatte.
Verstehe.
Und jetzt schaue ich mal, was dabei rauskommt und vielleicht bin ich danach auch total unglücklich, aber ich dachte mir jetzt einfach mal so, das ist mir jetzt irgendwie zwei Euro im Monat wert.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Sieht deutlich besser aus.
Weil sonst, wenn du alles fertig gerippt hast, dann sagst du Bescheid, ich habe da so eine Backup-Lösung am Start. Dann kann ich dir...
Ja, wir können ja unsere Backups mal gegenseitig hosten.
Wir können mal die sich gegenseitig decken lassen, ja?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt besonders aufregende Musik im Angebot hätte, aber vielleicht magst du ja das eine oder andere.
Obwohl, habe ich bestimmt alle schon.
Ich bin Kate Bush-Fan, ja. Ich bin ja von wenigen Dingen überhaupt richtig Fan, aber Kate Bush gehört definitiv in die erste Reihe.
Die tiefste 80er.
Nee, auch 90er, auch 2000er.
Ich habe ja letztens mit einem mich noch so ein bisschen über Brexit unterhalten und der meinte, die Engländer, die können ja zum Teufel gehen oder wie auch immer, die brauchen keiner, weil die haben ja noch nie irgendwas Tolles gemacht. Da habe ich gesagt, na doch, eine Sache können sie. Und dann hat er schon überlegt, was das denn sein könnte. Das finde ich wirklich nicht ein und meine ich, na doch, Musik können sie. Und dann meinte er, stimmt, hast du recht.
Ich meine, die haben jetzt Boris Johnson.
Den werden sie jetzt auch brauchen. Den werden sie jetzt auch brauchen.
Ich habe kurz mal die Timeline geguckt.
Ich meine, wenn er jetzt irgendwie Ministry for Agriculture, Fishery and Food oder Silly Walks wäre oder so was, ja, das könnte er bestimmt gut.
Silly Haircuts würde ganz gut sein.
Silly Haircuts, Ministry for Silly Haircuts and Walks. Ja, aber nicht...
Oh, das ist schon wirklich absurd, oder?
Aber das ist doch die gerechte Strafe eigentlich. Dass der Mann jetzt Außenminister machen muss, oder?
Für wen ist das jetzt die gerechte Strafe?
Für die, die mit ihm zu tun haben.
Für ihn selber, weiß ich nicht.
Wird doch überall nur ausgepfiffen.
Häben.
Was denkt sich diese Frau?
Das ist ja so ein...
Wahrscheinlich irgendein komischer Deal, das stand vorher schon fest.
Jetzt haben die auch so eine Merkel, ne?
Die stand ja auch schon rum mit der Romme, ne?
Nur die Amis sind wieder hinterher.
Ach, das ist auch noch?
Irgendwo habe ich ein Bild vorbeifletzten sehen, wo sie auch mit der Merkel-Romme schon rum stand.
Also, ich meine, die hat erstaunlich viele Parallelen mit Merkel. Also, sie ist irgendwie die Pastorentochter, Kinderlos.
Physikerin.
Genau, ich weiß nicht, ob sie Physikerin ist, aber auf jeden Fall akademisch gebildet. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was sie für ein Studium genossen hat. Also, gut, es gibt sicherlich noch mehr Vergleiche, die man heranziehen kann. Keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall ist Boris Johnson jetzt der Chef von GCHQ.
Was, die gehören zum Außenministerium? Was? Na, GCHQ ist doch keine Unterabteilung.
Das heißt, wenn wir so einen G7 haben, dann sitzen da nur noch Frauen, während die Clinton auch erstmal dran ist?
Women's World.
Und Putin mittendrin.
Ob es dann auch so ein Sexismus-Debatte gibt, wenn eine von den Frauen so einen Typen die Hand auf die Schulter legt?
Bestimmt. Aber was ich viel interessanter finde, ist so, es wird dann endlich mal die Frage beantwortet, können auch Frauen unseren Planeten zerstören? Oder geht das eigentlich nur mit Männern?
Ich glaube, die kriegen das hin.
Du meinst...
Team-Meeting demnächst.
Was hast du ein Team-Meeting? Jetzt?
Ne, demnächst.
Wie demnächst?
Sieben Stunden, sechseinhalb?
Ja, unser Team dröselt ja gerade noch einen nach Berlin. Ein paar Leute sind noch in einer anderen Zeitzone.
Ne, das ist okay. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie auch alles rübergebracht. Ich weiß gar nicht, haben wir schon einen Termin für die nächste Insel? Jetzt kommt so ein bisschen Sommerpause.
Bei mir im Kalender tauchte kein weiterer Termin auf.
Das war jetzt die letzte Freak Show.
Dann können wir noch ein bisschen machen.
Also zumindest...
Also in zwei Wochen ginge bei mir. Danach wollte ich dann wirklich nach Schweden.
Aber eigentlich hätten wir wegen Fußball jetzt ja nicht ausfallen lassen müssen. Hat sich ja gar nicht gelohnt.
Na ja, weiß man ja nicht. Aber wir waren halt mal... Wir haben es ja nicht ausfallen. Wir haben es ja nur verschoben in einer Woche. Also es ist ja noch mehr als weniger gewesen.
Eine Woche haben wir uns jetzt eingeholt, könnte man sagen.
Also in zwei Wochen müssen wir uns noch mal unterhalten. Das könnte sogar noch klappen. Danach ist auf jeden Fall Sommerpause.
Ist der Sommer nicht schon vorbei?
Ja, jetzt fangen die Ferien jetzt irgendwie an, oder? Sind schon, oder? Und Mitte Juli fangen die Ferien an.
Nächste Woche fangen die Ferien an.
Mein neuer Lieblingswitz erzählen, woran erkennt man den Sommer in Berlin? Pfützen sind nicht gefroren.
Oder auch, wie Hucke irgendwann mal meinte, Sommer in Berlin, der schönste Tag des Jahres.
Ach, wir haben auch schöne Sommer. Wir haben schöne Früh und schöne Spätsommer.
Oh, na gut, dass wir immer so viele schlechte Witze am Start haben.
Wobei das ja auch nicht stimmt bei Hucke, nicht Hucke, weil Tobias ja vorhin das Bild gezeigt hat, dass heute sein Balkon voll mit, also nicht Schnee, aber mit Hagel war, sodass es wirklich aussah, als wenn es geschneit hätte. Also haben wir jetzt vergessen zu posten, aber das ist gar nicht so abwegig mit den gefrorenen Pfützen.
Genau. Der Chat beklagt kein Camp dieses Jahr.
Nächstes Jahr wieder.
Ich fahre aufs Camp.
Ach so, aufs EMF?
Wenn mir noch irgendwas Dramatisches dazwischenkommt, werde ich da sein.
Ja, Brexit ist dazwischen gekommen.
Das macht es billiger. Warum? Das Pfund ist irgendwie in den Keller gefallen.
Du meinst, England lebt jetzt auch so voll zum Tourismusland?
Letztes Jahr, als ich da gelebt habe, war das Pfund auf dem höchsten Kurs gegenüber dem Euro seit Langem. Ich meine, es ist trotzdem noch immer alles teuer.
Ich habe noch am selben Tag, als das rauskam, Freunden von mir, die in London wohnen, aber in Euro bezahlt werden, zur drastischen Mietsenkung gratuliert. Das macht sich für die echt bezahlbar. Bezahlbar? Das macht die Wohnung bezahlbar.
Ja, aber sind das dann keine Briten?
Nee, aber es sind Leute, die da wohnen.
Da werden sie aber demnächst rausgeschmissen. Na dann ist recht.
Sie konsumieren ja, das wird ja mal gerne gesehen. Geld ausgeben wird ja mal gerne gesehen.
Alle Ausländer müssen jetzt raus, weil England muss jetzt den Englandern gehören und irgendeinem Scheiß.
Nee, so läuft das nicht. Da gibt es schon Regeln. Es ist hier mit dem Neuseeland. Du musst entweder die Sprache gut können oder eine Ausbildung haben oder viel Geld haben, wenn du da bleiben möchtest. Also mit viel Geld kann man immer alles regeln.
Weißt du, einfach links und rechts eine Watschen. So Dish, Dish. Und wenn sie fragen, warum, gleich nochmal. Dish, Dish, hinterher. So muss das laufen. Ich möchte jetzt ein halbes Jahr nichts anderes sehen. Nur Boris Johnson, wie er betröppelt, außer...
Von alleine hängt.
Mit blutiger Nase irgendwie so.
Sein Spitzname wird Bon Johnson.
Ein Kollege von mir, der hat erzählt, er macht sich jetzt immer den Spaß, wenn ein Recruiter ihn anschreibt und ihm einen Job in London anbieten will. Dass er ihm dann meint so, ja also UK und Brexit, das geht überhaupt nicht. Das täte ihm ja leid, aber das wäre jetzt kein sicheres Drittland mehr. Und da könnte er also den Job, das ginge überhaupt nicht.
Ja, was heißt denn Witz?
Er macht sich den Spaß.
Ja, es ist ja gar kein Spaß mehr, das ist ja schon alles total ernst. Also hier, was ja auch absehbar war, im Science-Bereich.
Jaja, die bluten schon.
Die bluten jetzt schon, aber so richtig. Weil die fliegen jetzt aus allen EU-Projekten raus.
Beziehungsweise alle Konsortien gucken, dass sie keine Engländer mit drin haben.
Genau, das meinte ich.
Weil sie Angst haben, die Fördermittel nicht zu bekommen, wenn sie Engländer bei ihnen drin haben.
Genau, und das ist eine absolut berechtigte Angst. Also das ist sogar sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich. Also die sind im Prinzip jetzt schon alle raus. Das legt deren Science-System... Also es gibt natürlich so Top-Forschungen, wo auch das Land selber viel reinsteckt, solange sie noch Kohle haben. Aber so der ganze Mittelbau, den ganzen normalen Universitäten und so weiter, sind hohen Maße von EU-Fördergeldern abhängig. Und das wird alles nicht lustig. Und jetzt auch noch mit diesem Maggie-Setscher-Verschnitt, ey, das macht mich alles total faul.
Wenn man doch mal einen Tag vorher gegoogelt hätte, was denn passiert, wenn man aus der...
Ja, aber das ist auch... Am Ende des Tages musste es vielleicht auch einfach sein. Auch wenn das jetzt irgendwie scheiße ist und so. Aber vielleicht ist es am Ende, ich habe mich immer von diesem Gedanken weit ferngehalten, aber vielleicht ist es am Ende auch reinigend für beide Seiten.
Auf jeden Fall.
Auch wenn man halt sagen muss, es wird dann jetzt auch nicht unbedingt einfacher.
Aber auch nicht für uns. Das bindet Ressourcen, massiv Ressourcen in Großbritannien. Aber natürlich auch bei uns, weil jetzt wird natürlich diese ganzen Verhandlungen und was wird denn da, da werden Millionen von Regulierungen und Verträgen angefasst und hin und her, die jetzt nochmal wieder gewendet, neu geschehen.
Es ist gelesen, dass sie nicht genug Ausgaben haben, um solche Verträge auszuhandeln.
Ausländer, da brauchen wir das ja. Für die Briten klar, die Briten müssen sich auch jede Scheiß Gesetz angucken, ob sie das jetzt noch so haben wollen oder nicht. Gerade die Sachen, die jetzt auf EU-Regularien basieren. Es gibt ja einmal diese Sachen, wo die EU-Quak direkt gilt in dem Mitgliedstaat. Okay, das ist einfach, das killen sie halt. Es ist nicht einfach, es sind auch Millionen von diesen Dingern, aber die killen sie dann halt einfach. Aber es gibt natürlich noch die anderen Sachen, die sie ja gänsefüßig zwangsweise in lokales Gesetz umrechnen mussten. Also umbauen mussten.
Du sprichst von Verordnung und Richtlinien.
Genau. Und das wird noch ein Zord, das alle auseinanderzuklambüsern.
Ja gut, aber unabhängig davon müssen sie ja im Prinzip trotzdem allen entsprechen, was die EU haben will, wenn sie Zugriff auf den Markt haben wollen.
Wenn sie EWR mitspielen wollen, ja klar. Das wollen sie definitiv. Die Frage ist, ob die anderen das auch wollen. Das kann ja auch Bestandteil des Bestrafungsteils sein, dass sie sagen, wir wollen draus, dann sollen wir euch im EWR mitspielen lassen.
EWR ist doch super, da kriegt man die Kohle von denen, aber sie dürfen nicht mitreden. Also das ist...
Ja und Personenfreizügigkeit ist auch im EWR. Genau, also da haben wir jetzt gar kein Problem. War jedenfalls sehr lustig auf dem Camp da in Frankreich. Da waren natürlich auch Briten dabei und die dann alle sozusagen unter großem Giole symbolisch aus dem Raum geschmissen wurden, haben wir natürlich nicht gemacht, aber die waren ziemlich scheiße drauf.
So, jetzt habe ich mir hier wieder irgendwas verklickt.
Und dann, übrigens dann, wenige Tage später, gegen Island verloren. Da gab es ein paar Leute, die haben echt gelitten. So, was so national stolz angeht.
Sogar Wales ist weitergekommen.
Na ja, wir sind ja auch in der Halbfinale, in zwei Wochen vielleicht Finale und dann gucken wir mal. Dann kommt ihr es nochmal.